programming throwdown episode 90 terminals and shells take it away jason hey everybody um yeah i have an interesting intro topic. Basically, this is something that actually happened a while ago but I wanted to talk about it right away but then at this point the show is actually popular enough that people I work with sometimes listen to the show and I didn't want to just jump into something that happened. That'd be kind of weird. So basically, I've been waiting until now to kind of talk about it. But, you know, it's about ambition and kind of the goods and bads of ambition, right? So what is ambition?
programming throwdown episode 90 terminals and shells take it away jason hey everybody um yeah i have an interesting intro topic. Basically, this is something that actually happened a while ago but I wanted to talk about it right away but then at this point the show is actually popular enough that people I work with sometimes listen to the show and I didn't want to just jump into something that happened. That'd be kind of weird. So basically, I've been waiting until now to kind of talk about it. But, you know, it's about ambition and kind of the goods and bads of ambition, right? So what is ambition?|||programming throwdown 第 90 期，关于终端与 Shell，杰森，请开始吧。大家好，嗯，是的，我有一个很有意思的开场话题。基本上，这是前不久发生的一件事，我本想马上拿出来聊聊，但现在这个节目已经挺受欢迎了，我共事的人有时也会听，我不想直接拿刚发生的事开刀。那样感觉有点怪。所以基本上，我一直憋到现在才聊。不过呢，这事儿跟野心有关，也就是野心的好与坏，对吧？那么，什么是野心呢？
Ambition is, you know, somebody sort of driving to kind of push themselves in some direction. Like they want to have more responsibility. They want to, you know, be, they want to do more, like work more hours if you're working hourly, things like that. And there's a lot of different reasons for this, right? Someone might want to make more money. Someone might want to, that seems like most obvious, but that's only one of maybe at least three or four things. I mean, someone could want more prestige and more honor. Like they might want a nice title that they don't have. Somebody might want, they might find the work more
Ambition is, you know, somebody sort of driving to kind of push themselves in some direction. Like they want to have more responsibility. They want to, you know, be, they want to do more, like work more hours if you're working hourly, things like that. And there's a lot of different reasons for this, right? Someone might want to make more money. Someone might want to, that seems like most obvious, but that's only one of maybe at least three or four things. I mean, someone could want more prestige and more honor. Like they might want a nice title that they don't have. Somebody might want, they might find the work more|||野心就是，你知道的，某人有一种驱动力，想把自身往某个方向推一把。比如他们想要承担更多责任。他们想要，你知道的，表现自己，想要做更多事，如果你按小时计酬，就会想多工作一些时间，诸如此类。这背后有很多不同的原因，对吧？有人可能想赚更多钱。有人可能想——这看起来最显而易见，但它大概只是三四种原因中的一种。我是说，有人可能想要更高的声望和荣誉。比如他们可能想要一个自己还没有的好头衔。有人可能想要，他们可能会觉得工作更
enjoyable. Like they might find what they're doing right now kind of too boring, right? Or someone might want influence they might want to be able to say things and people like to some degree have to listen to them right these are all kind of reasons for um ambition there's probably others as well and they're not inherently bad things i mean i think that that's sort of what drives a lot of people but where it becomes a problem is when when people don't recognize um like they just don't know kind of where they're at and this is one of those things that i i uh like looking back on my career this is one of the things that i didn't have a good sense of either so like when i was a junior engineer i thought senior engineers were just
enjoyable. Like they might find what they're doing right now kind of too boring, right? Or someone might want influence they might want to be able to say things and people like to some degree have to listen to them right these are all kind of reasons for um ambition there's probably others as well and they're not inherently bad things i mean i think that that's sort of what drives a lot of people but where it becomes a problem is when when people don't recognize um like they just don't know kind of where they're at and this is one of those things that i i uh like looking back on my career this is one of the things that i didn't have a good sense of either so like when i was a junior engineer i thought senior engineers were just|||有意思。比如他们可能会觉得现在做的事情有点无聊，对吧？或者有人想要影响力，他们希望自己说的话别人在某种程度上不得不听，对吧？这些都是产生野心的原因，可能还有其他原因，而且它们本身并不是坏事，我是说，我觉得这就是驱动许多人的动力所在。但问题在于，当人们意识不到——比如他们根本不知道自己处在什么位置时，这就成了问题。这也是我回首自己的职业生涯时，同样没有清晰认知的事情之一。所以，当我还是个初级工程师时，我觉得高级工程师不过是
people who coded slower than I did. Right. And I thought managers were people who did nothing. And I thought directors were just people who who, you know, wrote like mass emails encouraging other people, you know. And then and then I became a senior engineer and I was doing all these design reviews. There were problems like if there were problems. Like if there were, if there wasn't good unit test coverage and then that caused an issue on the customer side, I would take a lot of heat for that. And we'd have to have discussions about that and why that happened, et cetera, et cetera. And that all took a lot of time. And so that was less time that I
people who coded slower than I did. Right. And I thought managers were people who did nothing. And I thought directors were just people who who, you know, wrote like mass emails encouraging other people, you know. And then and then I became a senior engineer and I was doing all these design reviews. There were problems like if there were problems. Like if there were, if there wasn't good unit test coverage and then that caused an issue on the customer side, I would take a lot of heat for that. And we'd have to have discussions about that and why that happened, et cetera, et cetera. And that all took a lot of time. And so that was less time that I|||写代码比我慢的人。对吧。我觉得经理就是什么都不干的人。我觉得总监就是那些，你知道的，写群发邮件来鼓励其他人的人。然后，后来我成了高级工程师，我开始做各种设计评审。如果出现问题的话——比如，如果没有做好单元测试覆盖率，导致客户那边出了问题，我要承受很大的压力。我们必须对此展开讨论，探讨为什么会发生这种情况，等等等等。这花去了大量的时间，因此我留给
spent writing code. And so I realized that, you know, that those senior engineers are actually doing things that are really important and they're very busy. And then, you know, now I've moved into being a manager and I realize there's a ton of work there too. I feel like I'm just kind of busy all the time. That's a pretty, you know, I guess that's one dimension of looking at it just in terms of busyness. But in general, it's as you kind of go through that job, go through your career, you kind of are exposed to the bigger and bigger picture. And sometimes there's people want to really, really rush ahead, but they could actually rush like so far that they end up kind of like collapsing under their own weight um so you get some role that's just just way too uh requires like way too much experience and the right kinds of experience and things like that and i was talking to somebody a while back who was kind of in that position and they were trying to figure out how to get sort of the next promotion as
spent writing code. And so I realized that, you know, that those senior engineers are actually doing things that are really important and they're very busy. And then, you know, now I've moved into being a manager and I realize there's a ton of work there too. I feel like I'm just kind of busy all the time. That's a pretty, you know, I guess that's one dimension of looking at it just in terms of busyness. But in general, it's as you kind of go through that job, go through your career, you kind of are exposed to the bigger and bigger picture. And sometimes there's people want to really, really rush ahead, but they could actually rush like so far that they end up kind of like collapsing under their own weight um so you get some role that's just just way too uh requires like way too much experience and the right kinds of experience and things like that and i was talking to somebody a while back who was kind of in that position and they were trying to figure out how to get sort of the next promotion as|||写代码的时间就变少了。所以我意识到，那些高级工程师实际上在做非常重要的事情，他们非常忙。然后，你知道的，现在我转型成了经理，我发现那里的工作量也大得惊人。我感觉自己好像一直在忙个不停。这是一个挺……你知道的，我想这只是从忙碌程度这个维度来看问题。但总的来说，随着你经历这份工作、经历你的职业生涯，你会接触到越来越宏大的全貌。有时有些人真的非常急于求成，但他们可能会冲得太快，以至于最后在自身的重量下压垮——所以你会看到有些职位，它简直太——需要太多的经验、以及正确类型的经验等等。不久前我和某个人聊过，他当时就处于那种位置，他们正试图弄清楚如何以最快速度获得
quickly as possible and they didn't realize like that they're already kind of in this kind of bad position. And it's kind of an example where ambition can kind of blind you a little bit. And what do you think? Have you had people like that? Have you been like that? And how do you how do you sort of deal with that, Patrick? I mean, I think part of it I remember being like, I guess you're pointing out part of it is like when you first start off and you think like, oh oh no one above me doesn't know all these new things i know coming out of school and then you learn i i my more recent uh bent on it has been a little bit like building up your gut feel that like there's a lot of things that you don't know whether a certain approach is going to be too fast or too slow and you don't want to become inflexible and say, look, I did it this way before and it didn't work. Therefore, it'll never work. But at the same
quickly as possible and they didn't realize like that they're already kind of in this kind of bad position. And it's kind of an example where ambition can kind of blind you a little bit. And what do you think? Have you had people like that? Have you been like that? And how do you how do you sort of deal with that, Patrick? I mean, I think part of it I remember being like, I guess you're pointing out part of it is like when you first start off and you think like, oh oh no one above me doesn't know all these new things i know coming out of school and then you learn i i my more recent uh bent on it has been a little bit like building up your gut feel that like there's a things that you don't know whether a certain approach is going to be too fast or too slow and you don't want to become inflexible and say, look, I did it this way before and it didn't work. Therefore, it'll never work. But at the same|||下一次晋升，而他们却没有意识到自己其实已经处在这样一种糟糕的境地中了。这就是野心会蒙蔽双眼的一个例子。你怎么看？你遇到过这样的人吗？你曾经也是这样吗？帕特里克，你通常是怎么处理这种情况的？我的意思是，部分原因我记得是——我想你指出的其中一点是，当你刚开始工作时，你会想：“哦，我头顶上的那些人根本不懂我刚从学校学来的这些新技术。”然后你懂得了——我最近对这件事的看法稍微有点改变，那就是建立你的直觉：有很多事情你并不知道某种方法是会太快还是太慢，你不想变得死板，说什么“听着，我以前用过这种方法，行不通，所以它永远也行不通”。但与此同时，
time, you need to feel for like where hidden complexity might lie or what are the most important parts to test if you're going to build a proof of concept of something and building up those things over time. And I think what you're sort of indicating is like young people don't junior to a new skill. You don't always you can't always appreciate what's happening above you. You only know that it's like beyond your scope. And it can look really bad to have that blind ambition where you say, look, I just want to be promoted. I know everything.
time, you need to feel for like where hidden complexity might lie or what are the most important parts to test if you're going to build a proof of concept of something and building up those things over time. And I think what you're sort of indicating is like young people don't junior to a new skill. You don't always you can't always appreciate what's happening above you. You only know that it's like beyond your scope. And it can look really bad to have that blind ambition where you say, look, I just want to be promoted. I know everything.|||你需要去感受隐藏的复杂性可能在哪里，或者如果你要为一个东西构建概念验证（PoC），哪些是最重要的测试部分，并在实践中一点点积累这些经验。我想你所表达的意思是，年轻人——作为新技能的初学者——你并不总是、你也无法总是理解你头顶上方正在发生的事情。你只知道那超出了你的能力范围。带着那种盲目的野心会显得非常糟糕，比如你说：“听着，我就是想晋升。我什么都知道。”
I'm excellent at my job. Whereas the people above you are going, well, it's clear you're not. Because you really can burn bridges. Yeah, that's true. So yeah so yeah i mean i have seen this i think it's important to i guess one of the concepts is like manage up because sometimes it's hard to know if your manager doesn't know what they're doing or you just don't know what they're doing um both are possible that's a really good point it's a really good point both are possible and oh And how do you how would you know if you think how would you know if you're ready for the next level?
I'm excellent at my job. Whereas the people above you are going, well, it's clear you're not. Because you really can burn bridges. Yeah, that's true. So yeah so yeah i mean i have seen this i think it's important to i guess one of the concepts is like manage up because sometimes it's hard to know if your manager doesn't know what they're doing or you just don't know what they're doing um both are possible that's a really good point it's a really good point both are possible and oh And how do you how would you know if you think how would you know if you're ready for the next level?|||“我很擅长我的工作。”而你上面的人则会想：“嗯，很明显你并不擅长。”因为你真的会把退路都烧断。是的，确实如此。所以，是的，我的确见过这种情况。我认为重要的一点是——我想其中一个概念就是“向上管理”（manage up），因为有时很难分清究竟是你的经理不知道自己在做什么，还是你不知道他们在做什么——这两种情况都有可能发生。这真是个极好的观点，真的太棒了，这两种情况都有可能。噢，那你怎么——如果你在考虑的话，你怎么知道自己是否已经准备好迎接下一个层级了呢？
Would you just go and ask your manager, say, am I ready for the next step? I will not answer your question and answer a different question. So I think to me, this is one of the reasons why I think it's important early on to move around a lot, like both within your current company and to some extent, don't be afraid to change companies. You don't want to do it too often, but too little is also dangerous. And part of that is every time I've ended up a new company, I always think this, like, what am I going to do? Oh, I don't know anything. How am I ever going to be productive? Why am I not getting work assigned?
Would you just go and ask your manager, say, am I ready for the next step? I will not answer your question and answer a different question. So I think to me, this is one of the reasons why I think it's important early on to move around a lot, like both within your current company and to some extent, don't be afraid to change companies. You don't want to do it too often, but too little is also dangerous. And part of that is every time I've ended up a new company, I always think this, like, what am I going to do? Oh, I don't know anything. How am I ever going to be productive? Why am I not getting work assigned?|||你是会直接去问经理说：“我准备好迈出下一步了吗？”我不会回答你的问题，而是来回答另一个问题。所以对我和我而言，这就是为什么我觉得在职业生涯早期多跳动几次很重要的原因之一，无论是在当前公司内部转岗，还是在某种程度上，不要害怕换公司。你不想频繁跳槽，但跳得太少同样很危险。部分原因在于，每次我到了一家新公司，我总是会这么想：“我该怎么办？噢，我什么都不会。我怎么才能产出成果？为什么没人给我分配工作？”
But then it always ends up working out. And I think it's sort of, that's so true. I think it's related to what you're, what you're kind of asking, like, how do you know? And the answer is you never do actually know. But it, like, it kind of tends to work out and you try to find someone who seems to know what's going on. So I also recently have, you know, started to do more kind of manager tasks and you know try to communicate to people that you know hey this is what i what i think it means to grow into your role um and seeing people one of the ways is seeing people come to a person and ask them for help not a person offering their snide advice or just doing code reviews but actually people coming in like genuinely wanting assistance in something um yeah and I think that's a good sign when you, when people come to ask
But then it always ends up working out. And I think it's sort of, that's so true. I think it's related to what you're, what you're kind of asking, like, how do you know? And the answer is you never do actually know. But it, like, it kind of tends to work out and you try to find someone who seems to know what's going on. So I also recently have, you know, started to do more kind of manager tasks and you know try to communicate to people that you know hey this is what i what i think it means to grow into your role um and seeing people one of the ways is seeing people come to a person and ask them for help not a person offering their snide advice or just doing code reviews but actually people coming in like genuinely wanting assistance in something um yeah and I think that's a good sign when you, when people come to ask|||但最后事情总能顺利解决。我觉得这——太对了。我觉得这和你在问的问题有关，比如：“你怎么知道？”答案是，你其实永远都不会真正知道。但它——它往往就是能顺利解决，而你会试着去寻找一个似乎明白状况的人。所以最近我也开始承担更多类似经理的工作，你知道的，试着跟人们沟通，让他们明白：“嘿，这就是我认为成长为能够胜任自己角色的人所意味着的东西。”观察人们的一种方式是，看到人们主动来找某人寻求帮助，而不是某人在那里阴阳怪气地提建议或者仅仅在做代码审查，而是人们真正带着寻求某项援助的愿望走过来——是的，我认为这是一个好迹象，当人们来向你
your opinion on something and not just like in a formality, but like they seem to actually want to engage with you because they think you're helpful to their problem. That's a good sign. You're growing. Right. And that you are probably becoming ready for the next role, but I mean, you never do know, right? Like that's right. Yeah Yeah, it's always and the thing is, the dynamics change, too. So for example, it could be, you know, let's say you start a company and you find some great product market fit. And the company is a roaring business. Well, then maybe you could be a manager, a director, you could be anything. And the world is your oyster, right? But then things could go completely south and then maybe even being a manager is really hard. I think another thing
your opinion on something and not just like in a formality, but like they seem to actually want to engage with you because they think you're helpful to their problem. That's a good sign. You're growing. Right. And that you are probably becoming ready for the next role, but I mean, you never do know, right? Like that's right. Yeah Yeah, it's always and the thing is, the dynamics change, too. So for example, it could be, you know, let's say you start a company and you find some great product market fit. And the company is a roaring business. Well, then maybe you could be a manager, a director, you could be anything. And the world is your oyster, right? But then things could go completely south and then maybe even being a manager is really hard. I think another thing|||征求某种意见时，不仅是走形式，而是他们似乎真的想跟你交流，因为他们觉得你对解决他们的问题有帮助。这是一个好迹象。说明你在成长。没错。并且你可能正准备好迎接下一个角色了，但我的意思是，你永远也无法确切知道，对吧？就像那是对的。是的，是的，情况总是这样，而且动态也是在变化的。举个例子，假设你创办了一家公司，找到了绝佳的产品市场契合点（PMF）。公司业务蒸蒸日上。好吧，那也许你可以当经理、当总监，你可以胜任任何职务。世界任你驰骋，对吧？但接着事情可能会急转直下，到那时，甚至连当个经理都会变得非常困难。我觉得还有一件事
too is, so okay, there might be, when I was a junior engineer, I would get really upset when things didn't really work out, especially if it wasn't my fault, right? So when things are sort of unfair or when you work really hard and then for other reasons, the project falls away, like maybe the contract negotiation broke down before, you know, the contract was signed and the whole thing gets canceled, right? And that stuff used to really frustrate me. But now think about this. Let's say you're a director of 200 employees, right? At any given time, one of those groups of people, one of those teams, or at least one of those employees is having some kind of crisis like that. And your job is to basically deal with all of these crises, you know, simultaneously.
too is, so okay, there might be, when I was a junior engineer, I would get really upset when things didn't really work out, especially if it wasn't my fault, right? So when things are sort of unfair or when you work really hard and then for other reasons, the project falls away, like maybe the contract negotiation broke down before, you know, the contract was signed and the whole thing gets canceled, right? And that stuff used to really frustrate me. But now think about this. Let's say you're a director of 200 employees, right? At any given time, one of those groups of people, one of those teams, or at least one of those employees is having some kind of crisis like that. And your job is to basically deal with all of these crises, you know, simultaneously.|||也是，好吧，可能会有这样的情况——当我还是个初级工程师时，每当事情进展不顺，我都会非常沮丧，尤其是当错不在我的时候，对吧？所以，当事情显得有点不公平，或者当你努力工作却因为其他原因导致项目黄了，比如合同还没签署，合同谈判就破裂了，整个项目直接取消了，对吧？以前这些事情真的会让我备受打击。但现在想想这个：假设你是一个管着 200 名员工的总监，对吧？在任何特定时间，这群人中的某一个、某一个团队、或者至少某一个员工，正在经历某种类似那样的危机。而你的工作基本上就是去处理所有这些危机，你知道的，同时处理。
And it just never ends. It's just there's always a big problem. And as soon as that problem is fixed, there's another problem somewhere else. And so that's one of the things I realized, you know, recently, or I guess later on in my career is that, yeah, the director is just kind of on fire all the time. And they have to be someone who can kind of jump into different roles. So at one point, my director was acting as a first level manager to a team where the manager had quit. And so you have to be able to jump into that role and at the same time, deal with crises across, I don't know, 10, 11 other teams that could just spring up at any time.
And it just never ends. It's just there's always a big problem. And as soon as that problem is fixed, there's another problem somewhere else. And so that's one of the things I realized, you know, recently, or I guess later on in my career is that, yeah, the director is just kind of on fire all the time. And they have to be someone who can kind of jump into different roles. So at one point, my director was acting as a first level manager to a team where the manager had quit. And so you have to be able to jump into that role and at the same time, deal with crises across, I don't know, 10, 11 other teams that could just spring up at any time.|||而且这永远没完没了。总会有个大问题出现。而一个问题刚解决，其他地方又会冒出另一个问题。所以这是我最近——或者说在我的职业生涯后期——意识到的一件事，那就是：是的，总监的处境基本上就是天天在救火。他们必须是那种能够随时跳进不同角色的人。所以曾有一段时间，我的总监兼任了一个经理离职的团队的一线经理。因此，你必须能够随时切换到那个角色，与此同时，还要应付其他十几个、大概十一支左右随时可能爆发危机的团队。
And all of that requires, it's almost like encapsulation to kind of draw it back to technology. It's like encapsulation where, you know, you might know about assembly code and they might learn about C code and you might, or maybe you can go learn that electricity and then like capacitors and things like that and and it all kind of builds on itself and so the director can deal with all these crises because none of them really affect him that much because he's experienced a lot of other crises and things like that and so that's that's uh that's really been eye-opening to kind of see that that role actually is really hard and it's actually it's not that fun so but i think also ambition can apply to even just technical growth or whatever
And all of that requires, it's almost like encapsulation to kind_of draw it back to technology. It's like encapsulation where, you know, you might know about assembly code and they might learn about C code and you might, or maybe you can go learn that electricity and then like capacitors and things like that and and it all kind of builds on itself and so the director can deal with all these crises because none of them really affect him that much because he's experienced a lot of other crises and things like that and so that's that's uh that's really been eye-opening to kind_of see that that role actually is really hard and it's actually it's not that fun so but i think also ambition can apply to even just technical growth or whatever|||这一切都需要——如果把它拉回到技术领域来比喻的话，这几乎就像是封装。就像封装那样，你知道的，你可能懂汇编代码，别人可能在学 C 代码，你可能——或者你可以去了解电学，然后是电容器之类的东西，这一切都是一层层建立在基础之上的。所以总监能够应对所有这些危机，因为没有哪一个危机能真正对产生多大影响，他经历过许多其他的危机等等。所以，看到那个角色实际上有多么艰难，真的让人大开眼界，而且它其实并没有那么好玩。不过，我觉得野心也可以应用在纯粹的技术成长或其他方面，
like taking on a coding problem or challenge or architecture you're not ready for can that's a bite you right so if if someone says hey i'm going to need this in a week and you're like it's an opportunity to say hey i'm going to tackle that but if it's more than you can chew like you also be careful because you're spending some amount of uh whatever invisible credits to kind of like take that task on and if you aren't able to you know return back more than the credits you spent then that's sort of a net loss for you so if you that's okay yep no totally one time i I ended up, I was tasked with writing a DSP. And you know me. I know nothing about C or low-level really anything.
like taking on a coding problem or challenge or architecture you're not ready for can that's a bite you right so if if someone says hey i'm going to need this in a week and you're like it's an opportunity to say hey i'm going to tackle that but if it's more than you can chew like you also be careful because you're spending some amount of uh whatever invisible credits to kind_of like take that task on and if you aren't able to you know return back more than the credits you spent then that's sort_of a net loss for you so if you that's okay yep no totally one time i I ended up, I was tasked with writing a DSP. And you know me. I know nothing about C or low-level really anything.|||比如接手你还没准备好的编码问题、挑战或架构，这会反噬你，对吧？所以如果有人说“嘿，我一周内需要这个”，而你觉得“这是一个出头的好机会，我要去搞定它”，但如果这超出了你的能力范围，你也得小心，因为你在消耗某种——不管怎么说——无形的信用去接下这个任务。如果你最后没能收回比消耗的信用更多的回报，那对你来说就是一笔纯亏损。所以如果你——那没关系，是的，完全如此。有一次，我最终被指派去编写一个数字信号处理（DSP）程序。你们也知道我。我对 C 语言或者底层开发可以说是一窍不通。
And yeah, in hindsight, I mean, it was a very poorly assigned task. But, you know, I was just way over my head. And it was extremely frustrating. And I think it's one of those things where I guess as a manager, you have to sort of assign people the right tasks and be on top of that and things like that. But you also, as an individual contributor, you need to be able to say like, okay, this is kind of beyond me. I need help.
And yeah, in hindsight, I mean, it was a very poorly assigned task. But, you know, I was just way over my head. And it was extremely frustrating. And I think it's one of those things where I guess as a manager, you have to sort_of assign people the right tasks and be on top of that and things like that. But you also, as an individual contributor, you need to be able to say like, okay, this is kind of beyond me. I need help.|||是的，事后回想起来，我的意思是，这是一个非常糟糕的任务分配。但是，你知道的，这完全超出了我的能力范围。这让人极其沮丧。我觉得这就是那种情况：作为经理，你必须给人们分配正确的任务，并对进展了如指掌；但作为个人贡献者（IC），你也需要能够开口说：“好吧，这有点超出我的能力了，我需要帮助。”
And you should be able to sort of swallow your pride and things like like that i think this comes a lot into interpersonal communication as well so like when i'm when you're when you're sort of describing this one of the things is knowing like when to ask for help versus when to just figure it out uh yeah and like falling behind on something and not telling your manager becomes like a problem if you if you end up like oh if you just told me a week ago i could have helped you out or we could have changed something around um and so trying to like read the situation and like monitor how other people are viewing things or how loaded their work is i mean i think a lot of this comes down to that right so if you fail on something but if you hadn't tried it no one else could have tried it either that's not a big deal if you took something that someone else easily could have fixed and you sort of like
And you should be able to sort_of swallow your pride and things like that i think this comes a lot into interpersonal communication as well so like when i'm when you're when you're sort_of describing this one of the things is knowing like when to ask for help versus when to just figure it out uh yeah and like falling behind on something and not telling your manager becomes like a problem if you if you end up like oh if you just told me a week ago i could have helped you out or we could have changed something around um and so trying to like read the situation and like monitor how other people are viewing things or how loaded their work is i mean i think a lot of this comes down to that right so if you fail on something but if you hadn't tried it no one else could have tried it either that's not a big deal if you took something that someone else easily could have fixed and you sort_of like|||你应当能够放下自尊，诸如此类。我觉得这很大程度上也涉及人际交往。所以，当你描述这一点时，其中一件事就是知道什么时候该寻求帮助，而什么时候该自己琢磨出来。是的，比如进度落后了却不告诉经理，这就成了一个问题——如果你最后闹得——“噢，你要是一个星期前告诉我，我本可以帮你的，或者我们可以调整一下方案。”所以，试着去揣摩局势，观察其他人是怎么看待事物的，或者他们的工作负荷有多重。我觉得很多事情都归结于这一点，对吧？所以，如果你在某件事上失败了，但如果你不去尝试，别人也无法尝试，那倒没什么大不了的；如果你揽下了别人本可以轻松搞定的事情，而你却——
take too long and botch it then that's a that's a that's more of a problem and no one's going to actually tell you which things align to your skill set best as well as you can do for yourself and some of that you also have to like kind of read the room like see how other people are feeling what they're doing and ultimately make sure you're on a good team which has opportunity growth and people are willing to let you sort of fail a little bit without sort of coming down on you yep yeah it totally makes sense yeah definitely stay in a lot of communication and don't feel bad about just saying look i don't know how to do this cool all right and also yeah i guess yeah your your manager you can be just i mean depends
take too long and botch it then that's a that's more of a problem and no one's going to actually tell you which things align to your skill set best as well as you can do for yourself and some of that you also have to like kind_of read the room like see how other people are feeling what they're doing and ultimately make sure you're on a good team which has opportunity growth and people are willing to let you sort_of fail a little bit without sort_of coming down on you yep yeah it totally makes sense yeah definitely stay in a lot of communication and don't feel bad about just saying look i don't know how to do this cool all right and also yeah i guess yeah your your manager you can be just i mean depends|||花了太长时间并把它搞砸了，那问题就大了。没有人会像你自己那样清楚地知道哪些事情最符合你的技能组合。有些时候，你还得察言观色，看看其他人的感受、他们在做什么，并最终确保你身处一个拥有成长机会的好团队，在那里人们愿意容忍你犯一点错，而不是对你大加指责。没错，这完全说得通。是的，一定要保持充分的沟通，如果不会做，就直说“我不知道怎么做”，不要为此感到不好意思。太好了，行吧。而且，是的，我想——你的经理，你大可以——我是说，这取决于
on the manager but you should be able to be just completely transparent with them and don't hesitate to go to your manager and say i want to be i don't know principal engineer tomorrow but then also you know take your manager's advice very seriously when they say you know this is where we think you're at and uh yeah i think ambition is good if used in the right way. All right, do you want to jump into news? Sure. So my first one is an article, I guess a GitHub repository of Jupyter notebooks or IPython.
on the manager but you should be able to be just completely transparent with them and don't hesitate to go to your manager and say i want to be i don't know principal engineer tomorrow but then also you know take your manager's advice very seriously when they say you know this is where we think you're at and uh yeah i think ambition is good if used in the right way. All right, do you want to jump into news? Sure. So my first one is an article, I guess a GitHub repository of Jupyter notebooks or IPython.|||具体的经理是谁，但你应该能够对他们完全透明，不要犹豫去找你的经理并说：“我想在明天就成为首席工程师。”但同时，也要非常认真地对待经理的建议，当他们说“我们认为你目前的水平在这里”时。是的，我觉得野心如果用对了地方是件好事。好了，我们要进入新闻环节吗？当然。我的第一条是一篇文章，准确地说是一个关于 Jupyter notebooks 或 IPython 的 GitHub 仓库。
And it's in GitHub called Common Amb common and Bayesian filters in Python. Uh, we'll have a link in the show notes. There's not a catchy title to this one. Sorry. Um, but two, two things are a couple of things that are interesting. So, um, first of all, I didn't know that this was a thing on GitHub now where you can click the dot I P Y N B I Python notebook. You can click on one of those in a GitHub repository,
And it's in GitHub called Common Amb common and Bayesian filters in Python. Uh, we'll have a link in the show notes. There's not a catchy title to this one. Sorry. Um, but two, two things are a couple of things that are interesting. So, um, first of all, I didn't know that this was a thing on GitHub now where you can click the dot I P Y N B I Python notebook. You can click on one of those in a GitHub repository,|||它在 GitHub 上，叫做 Common Amb common and Bayesian filters in Python（Python 中的常用与贝叶斯滤波器）。嗯，我们会在节目简介中附上链接。这个没有一个很吸引人的标题，抱歉。不过，有两件——有几件有意思的事。首先，我以前不知道 GitHub 现在有这种功能，你可以点击后缀名为 `.ipynb` 的 IPython notebook 文件。你可以在 GitHub 仓库里直接点击其中一个，
and it'll actually load it up for you. Yeah, isn't that amazing? That's pretty cool. I'm not the biggest Python person, so maybe everyone else already knew this. But the second thing is, if you've never come across common filtering or just Bayesian filtering in general,
and it'll actually load it up for you. Yeah, isn't that amazing? That's pretty cool. I'm not the biggest Python person, so maybe everyone else already knew this. But the second thing is, if you've never come across common filtering or just Bayesian filtering in general,|||它实际上会为你直接加载并渲染好。是的，这不是很神奇吗？挺酷的。我不是个狂热的 Python 玩家，所以也许其他人早就知道了。但第二件事是，如果你从未接触过卡尔曼滤波（common filtering，注：原文口误，实为 Kalman filtering），或者广义上的贝叶斯滤波，
and what that means, Jason mentioned DSP work. If you do embedded processing, if you're, I mean, it actually comes up in lots of different things. If you're taking mostly, I guess, observations of the real world where some, whatever you're using for your sensor can be noisy. I think we've probably talked about this a little bit before, but whenever you're sort of taking a measurement and that measurement is prone to some amount of error and you want to have an understanding about what your belief of the real value is as you take these samples over time so so an example is if you get a gps coordinate off of the gps antenna in your phone that has some error in it that error kind
and what that means, Jason mentioned DSP work. If you do embedded processing, if you're, I mean, it actually comes up in lots of different things. If you're taking mostly, I guess, observations of the real world where some, whatever you're using for your sensor can be noisy. I think we've probably talked about this a little bit before, but whenever you're sort_of taking a measurement and that measurement is prone to some amount of error and you want to have an understanding about what your belief of the real value is as you take these samples over time so so an example is if you get a gps coordinate off of the gps antenna in your phone that has some error in it that error kind|||以及这意味着什么——杰森刚才提到了数字信号处理（DSP）工作。如果你从事嵌入式处理，如果你——我的意思是，它实际上会出现在许多不同的场景中。如果你在对真实世界进行观测——无论你用来做传感器的设备可能会带来多少噪声。我想我们以前可能稍微讨论过这个，但每当你进行某种测量，而该测量又容易产生一定误差，并且你想在随着时间推移不断采集这些样本的过程中，弄清楚你对真实数值的信念是什么时——举个例子，如果你从手机的 GPS 天空中获取了一个 GPS 坐标，它包含一些误差，那个误差会随着时间
of moves around over time so if you keep your phone in one spot and you keep reading samples over time over time all of the samples average out to you know probably very close to your location with with maybe a much smaller bias than any single sample but what do you do if you're also moving like what if your phone's moving you can't just sort of like accumulate all the samples for a minute and then average them you'll get a really bad answer and so right common filter is a way of sort of taking those uh describing statistically how to sort of take those measurements and use a bayesian update process and like kind of update your belief so you take a measurement you uh input the measurement into your sort of model and then you update the model to reflect that new measurement and then you get your sort of new estimate of where you are.
of moves around over time so if you keep your phone in one spot and you keep reading samples over time over time all of the samples average out to you know probably very close to your location with with maybe a much smaller bias than any single sample but what do you do if you're also moving like what if your phone's moving you can't just sort_of like accumulate all the samples for a minute and then average them you'll get a really bad answer and so right common filter is a way of sort_of taking those uh describing statistically how to sort_of take those measurements and use a bayesian update process and like kind_of update your belief so you take a measurement you uh input the measurement into your sort_of model and then you update the model to reflect that new measurement and then you get your sort_of new estimate of where you are.|||不断漂移。所以如果你把手机放在一个地方，持续读取一段时间的样本，随着时间推移，所有样本的平均值——你知道的——大概会非常接近你的实际位置，其偏差可能比任何单个样本都要小得多。但如果你也在移动该怎么办呢？比如你的手机在移动，你不能只是把所有的样本累积一分钟然后求平均，那样你会得到一个非常糟糕的结果。所以，没错，卡尔曼滤波就是这样一种方法：从统计学角度描述如何处理这些测量值，并使用贝叶斯更新过程来更新你的信念。所以你获取一个测量值，将该测量值输入到你的模型中，然后更新模型以反映这一新测量结果，最后你就能得到关于你所在位置的新估计。
Yeah, the biggest thing about, the reason why Kalman filters are important is that they handle the covariance, right? So for example, you could have a set of numbers and just take the last, let's say there's just one signal. You could just take the last thousand samples and average them, and you're done. But then the issue is what if there are two signals and what if they relate to each other?
Yeah, the biggest thing about, the reason why Kalman filters are important is that they handle the covariance, right? So for example, you could have a set of numbers and just take the last, let's say there's just one signal. You could just take the last thousands of samples and average them, and you're done. But then the issue is what if there are two signals and what if they relate to each other?|||是的，最重要的一点——卡尔曼滤波之所以重要，是因为它们能处理协方差，对吧？所以，举个例子，你可以有一组数字，然后只取最后——比方说只有一个信号。你大可只取最后数千个样本并求平均，这就完事了。但问题是，如果有两个信号，并且它们相互关联呢？
So when one goes up, the other one also goes up. Or when one goes up, the other one also goes down. Then that relationship, you should be able to take advantage of that. So if one is going up, you shouldn't have to collect the average to know that the other one's going to go down. And that's what the column filter does. So these are enormously powerful. They come up in all sorts of use cases and examples. And this GitHub repository, I guess, is sort of like an interactive book.
So when one goes up, the other one also goes up. Or when one goes up, the other one also downs. Then that relationship, you should be able to take advantage of that. So if one is going up, you shouldn't have to collect the average to know that the other one's going to go down. And that's what the column filter does. So these are enormously powerful. They come up in all sorts of use cases and examples. And this GitHub repository, I guess, is sort_of like an interactive book.|||所以当一个上升时，另一个也上升。或者当一个上升时，另一个下降。那么这种关系，你应该能够加以利用。所以如果其中一个在上升，你本不必收集平均值就能知道另一个会下降。这就是卡尔曼滤波器所做的事情。所以这些东西极其强大。它们会出现在各种各样的用例和示例中。而这个 GitHub 仓库，我想，有点像一本交互式的书。
And I didn't go through all of it, but I went through a little bit of reading it and trying, you know, looking at some of the first first chapters examples. Now, that was a really good descriptive way of doing it. This is a really complex topic. It took me many tries at trying to understand common filters before it sort of clicked. I guess this isn't really my background or my area. So maybe that's my excuse or maybe I'm just really bad at this stuff. Well, common filters actually depends on a lot of knowledge. And to jump right into it, I mean, without like a background and like Bayesian stats and stuff like that, it's a challenge. I mean, you probably have to cover a lot of background.
And I didn't go through all of it, but I went through a little bit of reading it and trying, you know, looking at some of the first first chapters examples. Now, that was a really good descriptive way of doing it. This is a very complex topic. It took me many tries at trying to understand common filters before it sort_of clicked. I guess this isn't really my background or my area. So maybe that's my excuse or maybe I'm just really bad at this stuff. Well, common filters actually depends on a lot of knowledge. And to jump right into it, I mean, without like a background and like Bayesian stats and stuff like that, it's a challenge. I mean, you probably have to cover a lot of background.|||我并没有看完所有内容，但我读了一小部分，并试着——你知道的，看了前几章的一些例子。那真是一种很好的描述方式。这是一个非常复杂的话题。我花了很长时间、尝试了很多次才最终真正理解卡尔曼滤波。我想这并不是我的专业背景或研究领域。所以这也许是我的借口，或者我在这方面真的很笨。好吧，卡尔曼滤波实际上依赖于大量的知识。如果要直接上手，我是说，如果没有贝叶斯统计之类的背景，那将是一个巨大的挑战。我的意思是，你可能得先补习大量的背景知识。
So I thought this was a pretty, maybe I'm somewhat tainted by having tried it a couple of times, but it seemed pretty good to me. I like the presentation. I like the style. I like the way they were sort of describing it. I didn't make it through all of the chapters. It gets pretty complicated into unscented common filters, extended common filters, particle filters. It sort of gets to some pretty advanced topics. So I didn't make it all the way through, but the sort of beginning stuff I thought was really useful. So I know this came up as early as college where there was times I kind of would have liked to know what these were and I didn't.
So I thought this was a pretty, maybe I'm somewhat tainted by having tried it a couple of times, but it seemed pretty good to me. I like the presentation. I like the style. I like the way they were sort_of describing it. I didn't make it through all of the chapters. It gets pretty complicated into unscented common filters, extended common filters, particle filters. It sort_of gets to some pretty advanced topics. So I didn't make it all the way through, but the sort_of beginning stuff I thought was really useful. So I know this came up as early as college where there was times I kind_of would have liked to know what these were and I didn't.|||所以我认为这相当不错——也许我因为之前尝试过几次而戴上了有色眼镜，但我觉得它确实挺好的。我喜欢它的排版。我喜欢它的风格。我喜欢他们描述事物的方式。我并没有读完所有的章节。内容变得相当复杂，涉及无迹卡尔曼滤波（unscented Kalman filter）、扩展卡尔曼滤波（extended Kalman filter）、粒子滤波等。它深入到了一些相当高级的主题。所以我没有坚持读完整本书，但开头的部分我觉得真的很有用。我知道早在大学时就接触过这东西，当时我其实挺想知道这些到底是什么，却并不了解。
So if that's you, I encourage you to check it out. Cool, that's awesome. Yeah, so my news is distributed consensus revised. That's a mouthful. So basically, okay, so consensus is, imagine you have a set of machines and they all have a one. Let's say they're all storing a number, and that number right now is one.
So if that's you, I encourage you to check it out. Cool, that's awesome. Yeah, so my news is distributed consensus revised. That's a mouthful. So basically, okay, so consensus is, imagine you have a set of machines and they all have a one. Let's say they're all storing a number, and that number right now is one.|||所以如果你也是这种情况，我鼓励你去看看。太棒了，这很酷。好的，我的新闻是：分布式共识修订版（Distributed Consensus Revised）。这名字真拗口。所以基本上——好吧，共识就是：想象一下，你有一组机器，它们各自都有一个数值——比方说它们都在存储一个数字，而这个数字现在是 1。
And they all want to increment that number. That could create some real challenges, right? Because you could kind of fan out this request. So let's say a machine fans out the request and says, okay, now the number is two. All the machines start doing that. Let's say that all happens at the same time. So everyone tells everyone else,
And they all want to increment that number. That could create some real challenges, right? Because you could kind_of fan out this request. So let's say a machine fans out the request and says, okay, now the number is two. All the machines start doing that. Let's say that all happens at the same time. So everyone tells everyone else,|||并且它们都想把这个数字加 1。这可能会带来一些真正的挑战，对吧？因为你可以将这个请求扇出（fan out）。假设有一台机器将请求扇出并说：“好了，现在这个数字是 2。”所有的机器都开始这么做。假设这一切都发生在同一时间。所以每个人都告诉其他人：
okay, yeah, the number is two now. So then now everyone has two, but that's not right. What they should have, if there's, let's say, 100 machines and it started out at one, it should be 101. But now everyone has two, but that's not right. What they should have, you know, if there's, let's say a hundred machines and it started out at one, it should be 101, but now everyone has two, right? So, or let's say it gets, you know, that's, let's say you have a case where two machines both want to change that number. One wants to set it to three, one wants to set it to five and a third machine gets both of these requests. well, what should it do? And so imagine, I mean, this happens a lot in the real world. Let's say you're on Amazon and you add something to your shopping cart.
okay, yeah, the number is two now. So then now everyone has two, but that's not right. What they should have, if there's, let's say, 100 machines and it started out at one, it should be 101. But now everyone has two, but that's not right. What they should have, you know, if there's, let's say a hundred machines and it started out at one, it should be 101, but now everyone has two, right? So, or let's say it gets, you know, that's, let's say you have a case where two machines both want to change that number. One wants to set it to three, one wants to set it to five and a third machine gets both of these requests. well, what should it do? And so imagine, I mean, this happens a lot in the real world. Let's say you're on Amazon and you add something to your shopping cart.|||“好吧，是的，现在这个数字是 2。”于是现在每个人手里都是 2，但这是不对的。它们应该拥有的——如果有，比方说 100 台机器，而且最初都是 1，那最终结果应该是 101。但现在每个人都有 2，这不对。它们应该拥有的——你知道的，如果有，比如说一百台机器，最初是 1，结果应该是 101，但现在每个人都有 2，对吧？或者，假设出现这种情况——你知道的，假设你遇到这样一种情况：两台机器都想修改这个数字，一台想把它设为 3，另一台想把它设为 5，而第三台机器同时收到了这两个请求。那么，它该怎么做呢？所以想象一下，我的意思是，这在现实世界中经常发生。假设你在亚马逊上购物，往购物车里添加了一件商品。
And let's say someone else, maybe even another country or something, adds the same item to their shopping cart and there's only one of those items, right? But you're both talking to different machines and each of those machines, like there has to be some resolution there, right? But you're both talking to different machines and each of those machines, like there has to be some resolution there, right? Now you can't, of course, if you had just one server, that'd be relatively easy, but that's not practical. You can't run Amazon on one server.
And let's say someone else, maybe even another country or something, adds the same item to their shopping cart and there's only one of those items, right? But you're both talking to different machines and each of those machines, like there has to be some resolution there, right? But you're both talking to different machines and each of those machines, like there has to be some resolution there, right? Now you can't, of course, if you had just one server, that'd be relatively easy, but that's not practical. You can't run Amazon on one server.|||假设另一个人——甚至可能是另一个国家的人——也将同样的商品加入了他们的购物车，而这种商品库存只有一件，对吧？但你们俩分别在与不同的机器进行通信，其中每一台机器——这里必须得有个解决方案才行，对吧？但你们俩都在和不同的机器对话，每台机器上——总得有一个决断机制，对吧？当然，如果你只有一台服务器，那事情就相对简单了，但这不切实际。你不可能在一台服务器上运行亚马逊。
So you have to handle this problem where there's this sort of conflict, like somebody has to win, right? So if you have a database with hundreds of machines, and you have two machines that are both saying, I own this item now, or this person, this person owns this item now, and that starts spreading, some of those machines are going to get, you know, a double count here, and they have to figure out what to do with that. It's extremely hard problem, actually. And, you know, there's a lot of research that goes into it it's gonna be hard to sort of dive into all of it but hopefully I've motivated you enough to read this article the article is great it's not you know the research paper or anything like that although it has a link to it but it's really a blog post from somebody who's trying to walk people through
So you have to handle this problem where there's this sort_of conflict, like somebody has to win, right? So if you have a database with hundreds of machines, and you have two machines that are both saying, I own this item now, or this person, this person owns this item now, and that starts spreading, some of those machines are going to get, you know, a double count here, and they have to figure out what to do with that. It's extremely hard problem, actually. And, you know, there's a lot of research that goes into it it's gonna be hard to sort_of dive into all of it but hopefully I've motivated you enough to read this article the article is great it's not you know the research paper or anything like that although it has a link to it but it's really a blog post from somebody who's trying to walk people through|||所以你必须处理这种存在冲突的问题，比如总得有人赢，对吧？因此，如果你有一个包含数百台机器的数据库，并且有两台机器都在说“这个商品现在归我了”或者“这个人、这个人现在拥有这个商品了”，而且这种消息开始扩散，其中一些机器就会在这里遇到——你知道的——重复计算的问题，它们必须弄清楚该如何处理这种情况。这实际上是一个极其困难的问题。而且，你知道的，这背后有大量的研究。要深入探讨所有这些内容会很难，但希望我提供的动力已经足够让你去阅读这篇文章了。这篇文章很棒，它不是那种——你知道的——学术研究论文之类的东西（虽然里面有指向论文的链接），它实际上是一篇博客文章，作者试图带读者一步步
how that all works it's pretty fascinating in my head I'm trying I's trying to walk people through how that all works. It's pretty fascinating. In my head, I'm trying to figure out an easy way to explain it. You really can't. You can imagine how hard that problem is. Part of it has to do with, you know, there's sort of a democratic aspect to it where if you have a majority, that majority tries to like dominate the other one. There's a process called leader election where you try to elect a leader and then whichever result that leader gets first
how that all works it's pretty fascinating in my head I'm trying I's trying to walk people through how that all works. It's pretty fascinating. In my head, I'm trying to figure out an easy way to explain it. You really can't. You can imagine how hard that problem is. Part of it has to do with, you know, there's sort_of a democratic aspect to it where if you have a majority, that majority tries to like dominate the other one. There's a process called leader election where you try to elect a leader and then whichever result that leader gets first|||了解这一切是如何运作的。这非常迷人。在我的脑海里，我正试着——我正试着带大家了解这一切是如何运作的。这非常迷人。在我的脑海中，我一直在试图找出一种简单的方式来解释它。但你真的做不到。你可以想象这个问题有多难。部分原因在于，你知道的，这里面带有一种民主的色彩，如果你拥有多数派，这个多数派就会试图去主导另一方。有一个过程叫作“领导者选举”（leader election），在这个过程中，你试着选举出一个领导者，然后无论哪个结果是这个领导者首先获得的
um becomes the right one so there's there's one machine who's the leader if that guy says that you bought the shoes then that other person's request gets canceled. Like Amazon has to revert, has to undo that purchase. But you get it, you're in. And so then you have this now meta problem, how do you elect this leader? The whole thing I think is super interesting, very complicated. I mean, you have to do latency in the network.
um becomes the right one so there's there's one machine who's the leader if that guy says that you bought the shoes then that other person's request gets canceled. Like Amazon has to revert, has to undo that purchase. But you get it, you're in. And so then you have this now meta problem, how do you elect this leader? The whole thing I think is super interesting, very complicated. I mean, you have to do latency in the network.|||——嗯，它就变成了正确的结果。所以会有一台机器作为领导者，如果那个家伙说你买下了这双鞋，那么另一个人的请求就会被取消。就像亚马逊必须恢复、必须撤销那笔购买一样。但你成功了，你买到了。于是现在你面临一个元问题（meta problem）：你该如何选举出这个领导者？整件事情我认为超级有趣，但也非常复杂。我的意思是，你必须考虑网络中的延迟。
You send a message, but it doesn't get to the other person right away. It might not even get to them at all. And the article is part one of a series that kind of walks through all of that. the person right away might not even get to them at all and article is part one of a series that kind of walks through all of that so yeah i guess this is the the normal algorithm people use here is paxos is that right but then there's like a simpler version raft and yep it's like i vaguely read them a couple times and it's like i see the gist like about at the level you sort of suggested
You send a message, but it doesn't get to the other person right away. It might not even get to them at all. And the article is part one of a series that kind_of walks through all of that. the person right away might not even get to them at all and article is part one of a series that kind_of walks through all of that so yeah i guess this is the the normal algorithm people use here is paxos is that right but then there's like a simpler version raft and yep it's like i vaguely read them a couple times and it's like i see the gist like about at the level you sort_of suggested|||你发送了一条消息，但它并不能立刻到达对方那里。甚至可能根本传不到。这篇文章是一个系列的第一部分，该系列全面梳理了所有这些内容。对方可能根本无法立刻收到——这篇文章是一个系列的第一部分，该系列带读者梳理了所有这些内容。所以，是的，我想人们在这里使用的标准算法是 Paxos，对吧？但接着又有一个更简单的版本叫 Raft。是的，我曾隐约读过它们好几次，大概就是你刚才所暗示的那个水平——我懂了其中的要点：
that there's latency and drop dropped messages uh and the network can be sort of subdivided and then reunited later and you need to make sure like that decisions can be made and that everyone eventually agrees on those decisions yep yeah exactly yeah so they made paxos and uh the original so zookeeper is is definitely the most popular open source library for this. Zookeeper is basically a little key value database, but all of the keys and all of the values are replicated. So every node has a copy of the entire database, which is why it can't be that big. But it's all kept up to date.
that there's latency and drop dropped messages uh and the network can be sort_of subdivided and then reunited later and you need to make sure like that decisions can be made and that everyone eventually agrees on those decisions yep yeah exactly yeah so they made paxos and uh the original so zookeeper is is definitely the most popular open source library for this. Zookeeper is basically a little key value database, but all of the keys and all of the values are replicated. So every node has a copy of the entire database, which is why it can't be that big. But it's all kept up to date.|||网络中存在延迟和丢包，而且网络可能会被划分为多个子网，随后又重新连通；你需要确保能够做出决策，并且每个人最终都能就这些决策达成一致。没错，完全正确。所以他们发明了 Paxos，然后——最初的……所以 Zookeeper 绝对是这方面最受欢迎的开源库。Zookeeper 基本上是一个小型键值数据库，但所有的键和所有的值都是被复制的。因此每个节点都拥有整个数据库的一个副本，这就是为什么它不能做得太大的原因。但所有这些副本都保持着同步更新。
And in the beginning, they used Paxos. But the issue with Paxos is it's, you know, when you deal with the real world, like theoretically, it's great. But once you go into the real world, the latency and networks that can drop out and things like that, it just had huge limitations. Like you would just never reach consensus. And so you have to have some hacks. And then over time, those hacks got more and more refined. They developed some really solid kind of mathematical bounds. And then the hacks became basically a better version of Paxos. And that's Raft.
And in the beginning, they used Paxos. But the issue with Paxos is it's, you know, when you deal with the real world, like theoretically, it's great. But once you go into the real world, the latency and networks that can drop out and things like that, it just had huge limitations. Like you would just never reach consensus. And so you have to have some hacks. And then over time, those hacks got more and more refined. They developed some really solid kind_of mathematical bounds. And then the hacks became basically a better version of Paxos. And that's Raft.|||在最初的时候，他们使用的是 Paxos。但 Paxos 的问题在于——你知道的，当你面对现实世界时，理论上它很棒。但一旦进入现实世界，面对网络延迟、可能掉线的网络等情况，它就有着巨大的局限性。比如你可能永远无法达成共识。因此你必须打一些补丁（hacks）。随着时间的推移，这些补丁变得越来越完善。他们开发出了一些非常坚实的数学边界。然后这些补丁基本上就演变成了 Paxos 的一个改进版本。那就是 Raft。
Cool. My next, I guess I sense a little bit of a theme to this week's, this month's articles. My next one is, this actually came out a while ago i saw this on hacker news um but i don't think we've talked about it and i i think it's pretty cool this is hn.academy and what it does is looks in hacker news posts for coursera courses or edx courses that are talked about or suggested as like ways to learn about something and aggregates them sort of over all time over the last month over the last year and and indicates like things so when you go to a site like coursera or edx or one of the other what is it moocs um
Cool. My next, I guess I sense a little bit of a theme to this week's, this month's articles. My next one is, this actually came out a while ago i saw this on hacker news um but i don't think we've talked about it and i i think it's pretty cool this is hn.academy and what it does is looks in hacker news posts for coursera courses or edx courses that are talked about or suggested as like ways to learn about something and aggregates them sort_of over all time over the last month over the last year and|||太酷了。我的下一篇——我感觉本周、本月的文章似乎有点主题连贯性。我的下一篇是：这其实是前段时间出来的，我在 Hacker News 上看到的，嗯，但我认为我们之前没聊过它，而且我觉得它挺酷的。这就是 `hn.academy`。它的作用是检索 Hacker News 上的帖子，寻找人们讨论的或建议作为学习某种途径的 Coursera 课程或 edx 课程，并把它们聚合起来——按历年、按上个月、按去年进行汇总，
then yep then you know you end up with this giant list of things it's like i don't know where to start which one of these are good or bad. I've done some before and I was like, ooh, this really feels like someone with a VHS camcorder in the back of the room just kind of like, it's cool that it's there, but I'm not clear I'm learning anything. And then other times like, ooh, this is really well done.
and indicates like things so when you go to a site like coursera or edx or one of the other what is it moocs um then yep then you know you end up with this giant list of things it's like i don't know where to start which one of these are good or bad. I've done some before and I was like, ooh, this really feels like someone with a VHS camcorder in the back of the room just kind_of like, it's cool that it's there, but I'm not clear I'm learning anything. And then other times like, ooh, this is really well done.|||并标明诸如此类的信息。所以当你访问像 Coursera、edx 或其他什么——MOOC（大规模开放在线课程）网站时，嗯，那么，没错，你知道的，你最后会面对一长串庞大的课程清单，感觉就像：“我不知道从哪里开始，这里面哪些好，哪些不好。”我以前上过一些，当时的感觉是：“噢，这真的就像有人拿着 VHS 摄像机在教室后面拍的一样，虽然有总比没有好，但我并不清楚自己到底学到了什么。”而另一些时候则会觉得：“噢，这个真的做得太棒了。”
So I think this is a good starting point for trying to filter those down to things which might be useful or practical. So there's some pretty good stuff in here, including things we've talked about before. So like from Nandgate to Tetris is on here as a course. There's jazz improvisation from the Berklee College of Music. Oh, that only had one citation. Okay, well, that's not that popular, I guess. Learning how to learn, quantum information science information science you know kind of list them out it's it's an interesting thing if you're nothing more than just a kind of uh cool courses to check out if that's something you're into cool that sounds awesome so is this is this like a meta
So I think this is a good starting point for trying to filter those down to things which might be useful or practical. So there's some pretty good stuff in here, including things we've talked about before. So like from Nandgate to Tetris is on here as a course. There's jazz improvisation from the Berklee College of Music. Oh, that only had one citation. Okay, well, that's not that popular, I guess. Learning how to learn, quantum information science information science you know kind_of list them out it's it's an interesting thing if you're nothing more than just a kind_of uh cool courses to check out if that's something you're into cool that sounds awesome so is this is this like a meta|||所以我认为这是一个很好的起点，可以帮你把它们过滤筛选出那些有用或实用的东西。这里面有一些相当不错的干货，包括我们以前讨论过的内容。比如“从与非门到俄罗斯方块”（From Nandgate to Tetris）作为一门课程就在上面。还有伯克利音乐学院的爵士即兴创作。哦，那个只有一次引用。好吧，那它大概没那么受欢迎。还有《学习如何学习》（Learning How to Learn）、量子信息科学……你知道的，它把这些都列了出来。如果你只是想找一些酷炫的课程去看看，而这又刚好对你的胃口，那它倒是一件挺有意思的事情。太酷了，听起来真棒。所以，这——这就像是一个元数据——
like a like an index of mooks so it's like at the end it's gonna point to one of these things this is a new trend i guess i don't know exactly what it is but the uh like awesome lists or whatever like oh yeah i don't know maybe i've missed the meme i don't i don't exactly understand what they are but i see those occasionally pop up where someone sort of makes like a giant list of like resources i would view it kind of like that yeah yeah that makes sense I think I call them listicles because like articles. Okay. Clever, I guess. All right. Cool. So we actually have something new. I'll talk about it briefly, a new part of the show. Um, you know, we have had over the years, many people email us, um, asking, um, us to basically talk about something that they're interested in. Um, and, and they wanted to sort of sponsor that discussion. Right. Um, and it's been everything from people, like, I'm not going to name any names of people trying to get us to talk about soda, like literally soda. Um, um,
like a like an index of mooks so it's like at the end it's gonna point to one of these things this is a new trend i guess i don't know exactly what it is but the uh like awesome lists or whatever like oh yeah i don't know maybe i've missed the meme i don't i don't exactly understand what they are but i see those occasionally pop up where someone sort_of makes like a giant list of like resources i would view it kind_of like that yeah yeah that makes sense I think I call them listicles because like articles. Okay. Clever, I guess. All right. Cool. So we actually have something new. I'll talk about it briefly, a new part of the show. Um, you know, have had over the years, many people email us, um, asking, um, us to basically talk about something that they're interested in. Um, and, and they wanted to sort_of sponsor that discussion. Right. Um, and it's been everything from people, like, I'm not going to name any names of people trying to get us to talk about soda, like literally soda. Um, um,|||就像是 MOOC 的索引一样？所以它最后会指向这些东西之一。我想这是一种新趋势，我不太清楚它到底是什么，但呃，就像各种 "awesome lists" 这种东西，哦，是的，我不知道，也许我错过了这个梗，我并不是很清楚它们到底是什么，但我偶尔会看到它们冒出来，有人会列出一长串像资源清单一样的东西，我大概就是这样看待它的。对，对，这说得通。我想我管它们叫清单体文章（listicles），因为它们就像清单加文章一样。好吧。我想这挺聪明的。好了。太棒了。所以我们其实有个新环节。我简要介绍一下，这是节目的一个新部分。嗯，你知道的，多年来，许多人给我们发电子邮件，嗯，要求——嗯，基本上是让我们聊聊他们感兴趣的事情。嗯，而且他们还想赞助那场讨论。对吧。嗯，各种各样的人都有，比如——我不点名那些试图让我们聊苏打水的人了，字面意思上的苏打水。嗯，嗯，
there's been everything from that to things which are really, really interesting. And actually to the point where some of the times we've even just said, hey, we won't do a sponsored discussion, but why don't you come on the show and talk about, spend a whole show with us. And some of our best shows actually have come out of that. But there still have been people who they want to sort of get a message out.
there's been everything from that to things which are really, really interesting. And actually to the point where some of the times we've even just said, hey, we won't do a sponsored discussion, but why don't you come on the show and talk about, spend a whole show with us. And some of our best shows actually have come out of that. But there still have been people who they want to sort_of get a message out.|||从那种话题到真正非常、非常有趣的话题应有尽有。甚至有时候我们干脆说：“嘿，我们不搞赞助讨论，但你为什么不直接上节目来聊呢，跟我们一起录完一整期节目。”我们有一些最棒的节目其实就是这么诞生的。但仍然有些人，他们只是想把某种信息传递出去。
And it's actually a really cool message, but it's one that we didn't find organically. So what we're going to do is we have this new area called Sponsored News, Sponsored News Link. And so this is going to be something that we're generally interested in. We're not going to try to fill this with anything. It's going to be something that we're, that, you know, we see
And it's actually a really cool message, but it's one that we didn't find organically. So what we're going to do is we have this new area called Sponsored News, Sponsored News Link. And so this is going to be something that we're generally interested in. We're not going to try to fill this with anything. It's going to be something that we're, that, you know, we see|||而且那确实是一个非常酷的信息，只不过这不是我们自己通过自然渠道发现的。所以我们要做的就是，开设一个名为“赞助新闻”（Sponsored News）、“赞助新闻链接”（Sponsored News Link）的新板块。所以这将是我们普遍感兴趣的内容。我们不会随便拿什么东西来填补这个板块。它必须是我们——你知道的——看到了之后会觉得：
that and we're like, wow, that's really cool. People should know about that. But, you know, total transparency, that's something that was presented to us. And so, you know, kind of keep that in mind. So our first ever sponsored link is the O'Reilly Open Source Software Conference. So this is pretty cool. Have you ever gone to, or had you ever gone to a conference before you started working, Patrick? I've never gone to a conference that wasn't only a part of my company's conference.
that and we're like, wow, that's really cool. People should know about that. But, you know, total transparency, that's something that was presented to us. And so, you know, kind_of keep that in mind. So our first ever sponsored link is the O'Reilly Open Source Software Conference. So this is pretty cool. Have you ever gone to, or had you ever gone to a conference before you started working, Patrick? I've never gone to a conference that wasn't only a part of my company's conference.|||“哇，这太酷了。大家应该了解一下。”但，你知道的，为了完全透明，这确实是别人呈递给我们的内容。所以，你知道的，心里要有个数。因此，我们的第一个赞助链接就是 O'Reilly 开源软件大会（O'Reilly Open Source Software Conference）。这挺酷的。在你开始工作之前，帕特里克，你曾去过、或者说参加过任何会议吗？我从来没有参加过不属于我公司内部会议的外部会议。
Really? Wait, seriously? Yeah. Wow. So you've never gone to like, I don't know, like just a generic conference. Like C++ conference, CppCon
Really? Wait, seriously? Yeah. Wow. So you've never gone to like, I don't know, like just a generic conference. Like C++ conference, CppCon|||真的吗？等等，认真的吗？对啊。哇。所以你从来没去过——我不知道，比如那种普通的通用会议。比如 C++ 大会、CppCon 这种？
nope never gone to that. Or just like a conference that had like yeah SIGGRAPH. You ever gone to SIGGRAPH? Nope. So I've never gone to like a research conference. I've never gone to no I just I was thinking about that I've never done it before. What about like a trade show? Like if you worked on a product. Nope.
nope never gone to that. Or just like a conference that had like yeah SIGGRAPH. You ever gone to SIGGRAPH? Nope. So I've never gone to like a research conference. I've never gone to no I just I was thinking about that I've never done it before. What about like a trade show? Like if you worked on a product. Nope.|||没有，从没去过。或者那种有——比如 SIGGRAPH 这样的会议。你去过 SIGGRAPH 吗？没有。所以我从来没去过学术研究会议。我从来没去过——不，我刚才在想这事儿，我以前确实从没去过。那行业展会呢？比如如果你参与过某个产品的开发。没有。
A product. Really? Okay. So I mean I've gone to stuff where it's like my company was hosting a bunch of people from the company to talk about the company that's i've been to like that before yeah right that makes sense okay i have been to a lot of conferences i'm a conferenceaholic um and i've gone to everything from actually i, just this month, I went to the Spark AI Summit. I'll be going to a conference at Netflix on Friday. And there's even another one. Oh, yeah, there's a VMware AI Summit.
A product. Really? Okay. So I mean I've gone to stuff where it's like my company was hosting a bunch of people from the company to talk about the company that's i've been to like that before yeah right that makes sense okay i have been to a lot of conferences i'm a conferenceaholic um and i've gone to everything from actually i, just this month, I went to the Spark AI Summit. I'll be going to a conference at Netflix on Friday. And there's another one. Oh, yeah, there's a VMware AI Summit.|||产品发布会。真的吗？好吧。我的意思是，我去过那种公司主办的活动，就是公司邀请了一群内部人员来开会讨论公司的事情，这种我以前参加过——对，这说得通。好吧，我参加过很多会议，我是个“会议狂魔”嗯，我去过各种各样的会议——实际上，就在这个月，我去了 Spark AI 峰会。星期五我还要去 Netflix 参加一个会议。还有另一个。哦，对了，还有一个 VMware AI 峰会。
Anyways, I go to a lot of conferences. It's cool to talk to people, see what they're doing. There's typically a vendor area. So that's people who have booths set up, things like that. There's a keynote hall. So there'll be one or two big talks where they expect a lot of people to go and they kind of have the right infrastructure for that. And then they have breakout sessions.
Anyways, I go to a lot of conferences. It's cool to talk to people, see what they're doing. There's typically a vendor area. So that's people who have booths set up, things like that. There's a keynote hall. So there'll be one or two big talks where they expect a lot of people to go and they kind_of have the right infrastructure for that. And then they have breakout sessions.|||总之，我参加了许多会议。跟人们交谈、看看他们在做什么，这感觉很酷。通常会有一个厂商展区。也就是那些搭建了展台的人所呆的地方。还有一个主题演讲大厅。在那里会有或者两场大型演讲，预计会有很多人去听，他们为此准备了合适的基础设施。然后还有分会场讨论（breakout sessions）。
So at any given time, there might be three or four people talking and you can only really see one at that time slot. And they try and space it out so that not all the, let's say, C++ people are talking at the same time or something like that. So Open Source Software Conference is actually one of the longest running open source conferences. It's been going on for about 20 years. And you can actually, if you go with the link that we're going to post in the show notes, you get 25% off admission to the conference. It's a little bit steep if you're not a student.
所以在任何给定的时间，可能都有三四个人在说话，而你在那个时间段内实际上只能看到一个人。他们会尽量错开时间，比方说，不要让所有的C++相关人员都在同一时间说话。所以开源软件大会实际上是历史最悠久的开源大会之一。它已经举办了大约20年了。实际上，如果你通过我们将在节目介绍中发布的链接去购买，你可以获得会议门票八折优惠。如果你不是学生的话，价格还是有点高。
So if you're not a student with the discount, it's about $750. Most people can get their company to kind of cover them. In my case, yeah, most of the time I get the company to cover it. If you're a student, then you can get some really nice discounts as well. You can look on the website for information there. And that could be, you know, high school student, college student, doesn't matter. But there's gonna be a lot of industry experts. There's gonna be folks from Google, like like Holden Carew is going to be there from Google.
所以如果你不是学生，没有折扣的话，门票大约是750美元。大多数人可以让公司来为他们报销。就我而言，是的，大多数时候我都是让公司报销的。如果你是学生，你也可以获得非常可观的折扣。你可以在网站上查看相关信息。那可能可以是，你知道的，高中生、大学生，都没关系。但这里会有很多行业专家。会有来自谷歌的人，比如霍尔顿·卡鲁（Holden Carew）将会代表谷歌出席。
Julian Simon is going to be there from Amazon. There's gonna be a lot of folks there. Definitely check it out. I think conferences are a really good way to learn kind of what the state of the art is. And the nice thing about open source is, you know, I've gone to conferences where folks talked about, you know, their amazing system they built
朱利安·西蒙（Julian Simon）将代表亚马逊出席。现场会有很多人。绝对值得去看一看。我认为会议是了解最先进技术（state of the art）的好方法。开源的好处在于，你知道的，我参加过一些会议，人们在会上谈论他们构建的令人惊叹的系统，
and we can't have access to it. It's like, here's this great stuff we built and it would take you you know five people working for three years to build the same thing um but this conference is all open source so everything somebody says um you can just download it off the internet and try it yourself which is pretty cool all right and with that time for it is time for book of the show my my book of the show is uh it's a little bit uh embarrassing but uh i i've been listening to oprah super soul podcast um i'm definitely not the stereotypical oprah um um subscriber but um this actually, I was flipping through the news on, I use an app Flipboard for news. And I generally like a lot of news about like, not necessarily self-improvement, but I
而我们却无法使用它。就像是，这是我们构建的棒极了的东西，而如果你要自己造出同样的东西，需要五个人工作三年。嗯，但这个会议是关于所有开源的，所以别人说的所有内容，嗯，你都可以直接从网上下载并自己尝试，这非常酷。好了，既然如此，现在是时候公布本期推荐的书籍了。我推荐的书是，嗯，有点，嗯，令人尴尬，但，嗯，我一直在听奥普拉的“灵魂呐喊”（Super Soul）播客。我绝对不是那种刻板印象中的奥普拉，嗯，嗯，订阅者，但，嗯，这其实是，我在浏览新闻时偶然看到的，我用Flipboard这个应用来看新闻。我通常喜欢很多关于，不一定是自我提升，但我
like positive stories. I like hearing people's success stories. I like, especially like entrepreneurs who succeeded. I like reading about their stories. And so over time, Flipboard has kind of picked up on that. You know, their algorithms or whatever have picked up on that. And so I guess that's how it showed me like top and most inspirational podcasts. And this was number one. I thought, OK, let me check this out. So this is the Oprah like from TV. Oh, yeah, yeah.
喜欢积极的故事。我喜欢听别人的成功故事。我特别喜欢那些成功的企业家。我喜欢阅读他们的故事。所以随着时间的推移，Flipboard基本上注意到了这一点。你知道的，他们的算法或其他什么注意到了这一点。所以我想这就是它为什么向我推荐最顶尖、最励志的播客的原因。而这个排名第一。我想，好吧，让我来看看。所以这就是电视里那个奥普拉。哦，对，对。
This is the Oprah. Apparently, she has a number of podcasts uh i found out later the super soul is just the one that i happen to be recommended in this article um and it's it's uh it's it's her just interviewing um um people who are kind of inspirational speakers and and thinkers and so like all the stereotypical inspirational speakers have an episode. So like there's a Tony Robbins episode, there's a Joel Osteen episode. There's a, you know, basically like pick any inspirational speaker that's really prominent and they have an episode on this, this thing. There's, there's like probably 30 or 40 episodes and yeah, I've been listening to them. They're pretty fun. I mean, it's, it's really fun to hear a bunch of people's perspective um and some of the stories are really powerful
这就是那个奥普拉。显然她有很多播客，嗯，我后来发现，这个“灵魂呐喊”只是碰巧在这篇文章中被推荐给我的那一个，而且它，它是，它就是她去采访，嗯，嗯，那些算是励志演说家和思想家的人。所以所有刻板印象中的励志演说家都有一期节目。比如有一期托尼·罗宾斯（Tony Robbins）的节目，有一期乔尔·奥斯汀（Joel Osteen）的节目。基本上，你知道的，随便挑一个真正知名的励志演说家，他们在这个平台上都有一期节目。这里大概有30到40期节目，是的，我一直在听。它们挺有意思的。我的意思是，听听大家的观点真的很有趣，而且其中一些故事非常有力量，
um so i've been having a lot of fun with it i do have a set of books queued up um that i have to get to and so i'm probably going to do that this this coming month but i definitely binge listened to uh to these the super soul podcast last month are the production values pretty high on the podcast oh yeah i mean this is yeah extremely high i mean it's very well edited um there's no downtime they they cut out you know even like from the uh you could tell that like they're cutting out parts of the interview that aren't that interesting it's you're not getting like uh it's not like a
嗯，所以我听得非常开心。我确实有一堆排队的书，嗯，我得去读，所以这个月我可能会去读那些书，但我上个月确实疯狂听了这些，“灵魂呐喊”播客。这个播客的制作水准很高吗？哦，对，我的意思是，这，非常高，我的意思是，它剪辑得非常好，嗯，没有空白时间，他们甚至会剪掉，你知道的，从，嗯，你可以看出他们剪掉了采访中那些不太有趣的片段，你得到的不是，嗯，它不像是一个
joe rogan type thing where you get every second um you're getting just the best let's say 30 minutes out of a what might be like a two-hour interview so i've noticed there's some new podcasts coming out and i to be fair although we do a podcast and have for many years i actually don't know that much about podcasting i know it shows um but or and i don't like editing the podcast um so the i've noticed there's a bunch of uh things where they do like they'll talk to various people and like have interviews and like cut like it's a whole almost like a very produced tv show versus as you said i was gonna say like our show or i guess joe rogan i have listened uh or watched one time when i think elon musk was on because it was in the news And so, yeah, it's a very sort of like much similar to our podcast.
乔·罗根（Joe Rogan）那种风格的东西，你会听到每一秒钟的内容，你得到的只是可能长达两个小时的采访中最精华的，比方说30分钟的内容。所以我注意到有一些新的播客出来了，公平地说，虽然我们做播客已经很多年了，但我其实对播客本身并不是那么了解。我知道有些节目，但或者说，我不喜欢剪辑播客。所以，我注意到有一堆，嗯，这样的内容：他们会和不同的人交谈，进行采访，然后进行剪辑，就像是一个制作精良的电视节目，而正如你所说的那样，我本来想说就像我们的节目，或者我想乔·罗根的节目，我曾经听过，或者看过一次，当时好像是埃隆·马斯克（Elon Musk）上节目，因为这在新闻里闹得沸沸扬扬。所以，是的，它是一种非常类似于我们播客的节目。
Like there is sort of a rough agenda, but it's just kind of like a free, like a train of consciousness sort of like conversation. And there's these other ones that have come out, though, that are very much like there's a segment and then they cut to an interview somewhere else and then cut back to this other thing. And you can tell it's out of order and they've stitched it together later almost like a you know talk show would be um and i find i i guess this is becoming like a thing man we were like podcasts are hot again yeah i mean when we were podcasting it uh it was like pretty hot and then it this is probably the third wave of it feels like it's happened a few times yeah this this is the third wave of podcasting. It feels like it's happened a few times. Yeah, this is the third wave and here we are, which is pretty cool.
就像有一个大致的议程，但它有点像是一种自由的、意识流式的对话。不过，现在涌现出其他一些播客，它们非常讲究，有一个板块，然后切到别处的采访，接着又切回另一个内容。你可以看出它们的顺序被打乱了，事后又被拼接在了一起，几乎就像是一个，你知道的，脱口秀节目那样，嗯，我发现，我猜这快要成为一种潮流了，老兄。我们当时还觉得播客又火起来了。是的，我的意思是，我们做播客的时候，它，挺火的，然后这大概是它的第三波浪潮了，感觉已经发生好几次了。是的，这，这是第三波浪潮，而我们正身处其中，这挺酷的。
Well, I don't have a podcast to recommend, but I do have a book. The book I just finished reading is Red Sister by Mark Lawrence, who I have not read a book from before, I don't believe. And this is the first book in a trilogy, which the third book in a trilogy, which the third book just came out this year. And this is a fantasy book, or at least the parts of it I've read are.
好吧，我没有播客要推荐，但我确实有一本书。我刚刚看完的书是马克·劳伦斯（Mark Lawrence）的《红修女》（Red Sister），在此之前我应该没有读过他的书。这是三部曲中的第一本，而这三部曲的第三本刚刚在今年出版。这是一本奇幻小说，或者说至少我读过的部分是这样的。
And again, I always struggle with this, but this is roughly about a peasant girl who has sort of like strange things happening around her and to her, and she ends up in a nunnery no a convent that's what it's called a convent oh um so she's with other nuns but there's uh there's this concept sort of like of old bloods so there's like these four races that had kind of like magical abilities and people in the sort of time of the books, uh, uh,
而且，我总是觉得这很难描述，但大概是关于一个农家女孩，她的身边和身上发生了一些奇怪的事情，她最终进了一个女修道院，不，是一个修女院，就是这么叫的，一个修女院。哦，嗯，所以她和其他修女在一起，但这里有，嗯，有一种类似于“古老血脉”的概念。所以有大约四个种族，它们拥有某种类似于魔法的能力，而在书籍的那个时期的，嗯，
storyline, um, some, some people sort of manifest those powers from those sort of like people that came before them. And so, um, in this convent,
故事情节中，嗯，有一些人会从那些类似于先于他们存在的人身上，显现出那些魔法力量。所以，嗯，在这个修女院里，
people have various magical abilities or no magical abilities. And they just sort of like are in the religion that the book sort of describes. Um, and it's, so it's sort of like a magical fantasy book um but i i really enjoyed it there it's it's pretty different to a lot of the other books i've read but doesn't it's a sort of what do they call like a coming of age story right like it starts with a small girl and she's growing up and she's like in school it's a very i guess a common trope um but i like that there are some twists to it so like the world that they're on is uh being covered in ice so basically the entire world is covered in ice except a band around the equator of i think it's
人们拥有各种各样的魔法能力，或者完全没有魔法能力。他们只是某种程度上遵循着书中描述的那种宗教。嗯，所以它有点像是一本带有魔法色彩的奇幻书，嗯，但我真的很喜欢它。它和我读过的许多其他书有很大不同，但它不属于那种，它们叫什么来着，成长小说对吧？就像它从一个小女孩开始，她慢慢长大，还在上学。我想这是一个非常常见的套路，但我喜欢它有一些意想不到的转折。比如他们生存的世界，嗯，正在被冰雪覆盖。所以基本上整个世界都被冰雪覆盖了，除了赤道附近的一条地带，我想大约是，
like around 100 miles or 50 miles or something so the world is sort of like slowly becoming covered in ice which is causing problems and sort of the past is getting covered up as the ice contracts. And then you learn some information about that and possibilities for the future. And so I've only read the first book, so I don't know how the series ends, but I thought it was pretty good. So I'll give it a recommendation. Not five stars for me, but a solid four stars. I finished it and I immediately started the second book.
大约100英里或50英里宽左右。所以世界正在慢慢被冰雪吞噬，这引发了各种问题，而且随着冰层收缩，过去的历史也被掩盖了。然后你会了解到一些关于这方面的信息以及未来的可能性。所以我也只读了第一本书，所以我不知道这个系列将如何结束，但我认为它相当不错。所以我推荐它。对我和来说不是五星，但稳稳的四星。我看完它之后，立刻就开始读第二本了。
So that's a pretty good recommendation, I guess. I haven guess i haven't finished that so the ice is expanding or contracting uh sorry the the band is getting narrower so the ice is expanding so their sun is dying their sun is dying and their world is becoming colder oh interesting so um but yeah so there's some interesting things i don't obviously like all the secrets aren't revealed in the first book of a three book trilogy, but I liked it. And I listened to that on Audible because my commute is long. And I, like I said, I already started on the second book.
所以这算是一个相当不错的推荐吧。我还没猜，我还没读完，所以冰是在扩张还是收缩？抱歉，冰带在变窄，所以冰在扩张。所以他们的太阳正在消亡，他们的太阳正在消亡，他们的世界变得越来越冷。哦，有意思。所以，嗯，是的，里面有一些有趣的东西。显然，三部曲的第一本并没有揭晓所有的秘密，但我很喜欢它。我在Audible上听的，因为我上下班通勤时间很长。而且，就像我说的，我已经开始听第二本了。
It's when I get to the end, I get nervous. This is how bad it is. If I see that my book is gonna end during my commute, I make sure to download another book so that I don't have to sit the sort of half of a commute, not listening to it. No, I'm not even kidding. This is so bad. So, so when it gets like within an hour of the end, I always make sure to download whatever book I'm going to listen to next. So I make the decision about what I'm listening to next beforehand so that I'm not sitting in the car. Like I don't have anything to listen to.
每当快要听完的时候，我就会开始紧张。事情就是这么糟糕。如果我发现我的书会在通勤路上听完，我就会确保再下载另一本，这样我就不用在半程通勤的路上无书可听了。不，我真的不是在开玩笑。这太糟糕了。所以，当距离结束还有一个小时左右的时候，我总是确保下载接下来要听的任何一本书。所以我会在事先决定好接下来要听什么，这样我就不会坐在车里，发现自己无东西可听了。
Oh my gosh. Well, I mean, at least you're you're not trying to download it while you're in the car halfway through. Yeah, that would be distracting. Probably. I wouldn't recommend that. Yeah, that's that. That's not good times.
天哪。好吧，我的意思是，至少你不是在车里听到一半时才尝试去下载。是的，那会让人分心的。大概吧。我不建议这样做。是的，那样，那可不是什么好时光。
That's and if you if you already have an audible subscription or if you don't want one, you can also help us out on Patreon. You go to Patreon dot com slash programming throw down also help us out on patreon um you can go to patreon.com slash programming throwdown and help us out on there we uh we've been able to get um you know a decent amount of advertising out on on on um on different platforms to try to get more people interested in the show and things like that and it's actually really um inspiring we've gotten a lot of emails from people recently who said hey you know just wanted to thank you i got into the show um um and and you know i've been able to do xyz
那是，如果你，如果你已经订阅了Audible，或者如果你不想要一个订阅，你也可以在Patreon上支持我们。你可以访问Patreon点com斜杠programming throw down，也可以在Patreon上支持我们，嗯，你可以访问patreon.com/programming throw down并在那里支持我们。我们，嗯，我们已经能够获得，嗯，你知道的，相当数量的广告投放，在，在，在不同的平台上，试图让更多的人对这个节目感兴趣，诸如此类的事情。这真的很，嗯，鼓舞人心。我们最近收到了很多人的电子邮件，他们说：“嘿，你知道的，只是想感谢你们，我开始收听这个节目了，嗯，嗯，而且，你知道的，我能够做X Y Z了。”
and we really appreciate that that's cool that's why we're doing it all right time for tool of the show my tool of the show is folly so folly is is a set of C++ libraries. Some of them are header-only libraries. Some of them you have to compile. But they do a variety of different tasks. I mean, it's almost like a boost, like the boost library, but just different. It does different things. The one that I used, which drew my attention to it, is Folly Future, which is pretty cool. The idea with Folly Future is, in my case, I had a set of tasks, and those tasks formed a DAG, directed acyclic graph. So imagine you have tasks A, B, C, D. Tasks A and B can run right away. Task C depends on task A and task D depends on tasks C and B. So A, B runs. B finishes. Doesn't matter, can't do
我们真的很感激这一点。这很酷，这就是我们做这件事的原因。好的，到了本期工具推荐时间。我推荐的工具是Folly。Folly是一套C++库。其中一些是仅包含头文件的库。有些则需要编译。但它们执行各种不同的任务。我的意思是，它有点像Boost，就像Boost库一样，但又有所不同。它做的事情不一样。我用过的那个吸引我注意力的库是Folly Future，它非常酷。Folly Future的想法是，就我而言，我有一组任务，这些任务构成了一个有向无环图（DAG）。假设你有任务A、B、C、D。任务A和B可以立即运行。任务C依赖于任务A，任务D依赖于任务C和B。所以A和B运行。B完成了。没关系，还不能做
anything yet. A finishes. Okay now I can run C. C finishes. Okay now I can run D. And so I had to, I had this this DA, and I wanted to execute it as quickly as possible. And it's kind of complicated. I mean, you could always pull, so you could sleep the processor for, let's say, a millisecond, and then you could check, see where you're at. But that's kind of slow, and this needed to run at really high scale, really, really large scale. So with this Folly future library, I was basically able to say, you have a set of what are called promises. And a promise is basically it's a set of function pointers that are going to get executed when you fulfill the promise. So in this case, you know, I had a promise for I had a promise for each of my dependencies so
任何事。A完成了。好吧，现在我可以运行C了。C完成了。好吧，现在我可以运行D了。因此我必须，我拥有这个有向无环图，并且我希望尽可能快地执行它。这有点复杂。我的意思是，你总是可以轮询（pull），所以你可以让处理器休眠，比方说一毫秒，然后你可以检查一下，看看你进行到哪一步了。但那有点慢，而这个程序需要在极高的规模、非常非常大的规模下运行。因此，有了这个Folly Future库，我基本上可以说，你有一组被称为“承诺”（promises）的东西。而一个承诺基本上就是一组函数指针，当你兑现承诺时，它们就会被执行。所以在这种情况下，你知道的，我有一个承诺，我有针对每个依赖项的承诺，所以
in other words there's a promise for a promise for B processor C promise for D and when when let's say a finished then it set that promise to true for a and then also set the promise to see for true set to the promise of promise to true for A, and then also set the promise to C for true, set the promise of C to true, which meant C could run. Then when B finished, then it set the promise for D. And so in this way, I didn't have to have any sleep in the code or anything like that. It could just instantly run.
换句话说，有一个针对A的承诺，一个针对B的承诺，处理C的承诺，针对D的承诺。当，当，比方说A完成了，那么它就把A的承诺设为真，然后也把，把，把A的承诺设为真，然后也把C的承诺设为真，把C的承诺设为真，这意味着C可以运行了。然后当B完成了，它就设置了D的承诺。通过这种方式，我的代码中就不需要任何睡眠或类似的东西了。它可以即时运行。
Now, under the hood, it has to be doing some type of polling, but it's extremely, extremely fast. No, no, no they're letting the operating system actually has support at like the os level so it doesn't have to pull it actually sleeps the process until it gets signaled to wake up yeah that's right that's right yeah i kind of didn't really i kind of misspoke there yeah sorry the operating system itself no you're totally right the operating system itself like the kernel is kind of i guess at some point the kernel is polling or doing some type of you know well it just has a registered list so it
现在，在底层，它肯定在做某种轮询，但它极其、极其快。不，不，不，它们让操作系统实际上在操作系统级别提供支持，所以它不需要轮询，它实际上会让进程休眠，直到接到唤醒的信号。对，就是这样，对，对。我刚才有点，我刚才有点说错了，是的，抱歉，操作系统本身，不，你完全正确，操作系统本身，比如内核，有点，我猜在某个时候内核在轮询或者做某种，你知道的，嗯，它只是有一个注册的列表，所以它
basically sort of think about kind of like a semaphore so it knows that hey when something is pushed into a channel or whatever like it knows to go wake up that process like it has a sort of lookup table and so it knows oh or you're calling like select is how that works like it goes to sleep and says like hey i'm interested in any one of these events and if one of those events sort of fires it goes hey who do i need to wake up and like have them execute oh that's how it makes sense it's even better than sleeping yeah so so uh yeah check out this library um there's a lot more than just features um but but uh that was the one that just happened to use right now um but yeah i thought it was really cool and uh and if you're
基本上，你可以把它想象成某种信号量（semaphore），所以它知道，嘿，当有什么东西被推入通道或其他什么时，它知道去唤醒那个进程。它有一个类似于查找表的机制，所以它知道，哦，或者你调用类似select的函数，这就是它的工作原理：它进入睡眠状态并说：“嘿，我对这些事件中的任何一个都很感兴趣，如果其中一个事件触发了，它就会说，‘我需要唤醒谁，让他们去执行？’”哦，原来是这样，这比单纯睡眠要好得多。是的，所以，是的，去看看这个库吧，里面不仅仅只有future（异步期物），还有很多其他东西，但，但，那是碰巧我目前正在使用的功能。不过，是的，我觉得它真的很酷。而且如果你
doing any c++ i highly recommend it wait so are you doing c++ now so yeah basically actually uh shameless plug um i presented at another conference speaking of conferences I presented at the F8 conference and you could actually go watch me but one of the things that we're working on is we do all this machine learning but then we also want to serve the model like at the end we want people to actually use the model and so we've built this serving library that you could run on a phone you could
正在编写任何C++代码，我强烈推荐它。等等，所以你现在在写C++吗？是的，基本上，实际上，厚颜无耻地打个广告，我在另一个会议上做过演讲，说到会议，我在F8会议上做过演讲，你实际上可以去看我的演讲。但我们正在做的事情之一是，我们做了所有这些机器学习，然后我们还想部署模型——最后我们希望人们真正使用这个模型。所以我们构建了这个服务库，你可以在手机上运行它，你可以在
run on um you know website on whatever you want and so uh i'm kind of helping out with that hey that's pretty cool um so the other thing is i said i have used futures in java so um i do actually it takes a while to get used to the sort of that paradigm but but i do actually prefer it for all the reasons you said it's better than the sort of like wait for this to be done um and then and then move on to the next thing and sort of doing that manually being able to sort of like chain the functions is seems more natural yep yeah totally did like that um my tool of the show is again a game because apparently it's the only thing I'm good for. And this one is one I found very recently, Golf Blitz.
嗯，你知道的，在网站上运行它，或者任何你想要的地方运行它。所以我正在帮忙做这件事。嘿，那挺酷的。嗯，所以另一件事是，我之前说过，我在Java中使用过future（期物），所以，嗯，我确实，适应那种范式需要一段时间，但出于你所说的一切原因，我确实更喜欢它。它比那种“等待这个完成，然后，然后转到下一项任务”并手动去做的方式要好，能够像这样把函数串联起来似乎更自然。是的，完全是这样，确实很喜欢那样。我本期推荐的工具又是一个游戏，因为显然这是我唯一擅长的领域。而这个游戏是我最近才发现的，叫《高尔夫闪电战》（Golf Blitz）。
So a word of warning, this is a free-to-play game. So if you can't deal with that, I'm sorry. Well, how do they make you suffer? No, okay, so here's the thing. So two things. One is it's a very casual game. I don't play in a way that I care um and so i don't actually even know what the i think the pay mechanism is to like upgrade your character faster you have to wait you have to get sort of open these envelopes
所以先提个醒，这是一个免费游玩的游戏。如果你受不了这个，我很抱歉。好吧，它们是怎么让你受折磨的？不，好吧，情况是这样的。两件事。第一，这是一个非常休闲的游戏。我玩的时候并不走心，嗯，所以其实我甚至不知道，我想付费机制是让你更快地升级角色，你必须等待，你必须打开这种信封，
and then the envelopes you get like power-ups and if you want to open the envelopes you have to wait or pay one of the five kinds of currencies in the game or whatever i don't know pay attention to it all i know is that you play uh with three other people online and i normally don't like online games but you basically are hitting a golf ball um and there's crazy courses where uh it's a very 2d thing which is a common trope i guess has happened before the the sort of like 2d golfer game um so you hit the ball but it's kind of funny because the balls can collide in air and you can bump into other people's balls and move them and um the the courses resemble sort of like roller coaster kind of like crazy crazy setups this isn't 2d yeah oh because it sounds like a
然后这些信封里你会得到各种能力提升（power-ups）。如果你想打开这些信封，你必须等待，或者用游戏里五种货币中的一种去支付，或者别的什么。我不管它，我没怎么注意。我只知道你是在网上和其他三个人一起玩。我通常不喜欢网络游戏，但你基本上就是在击打一个高尔夫球，里面有疯狂的球场，这是一个非常2D的游戏，我想这很常见，以前也出现过那种2D高尔夫球手游戏。所以你击打球，但这挺搞笑的，因为球可以在空中碰撞，你可以撞击别人的球并把它们弹开，并且，球场类似于过山车那种疯狂的设置。这不是2D的吗？是的。哦，因为听起来像是一个
3d thing with all the physics or whatever yeah but 2d um okay sorry but when you hit the ball it goes up right yeah oh you're saying but like all the graphics are 2d yeah so it goes yeah so it's all 2d and the and the game is like you know like level like uh you might the hole might be directly under where you're standing she might be standing on sort of a floating island and then there's like two islands to either side of your island and then a line island underneath you've lower and you need to like hit from one to the other and then from the other back to the middle and you're trying to be the first one to get into the hole okay all right and so it's like the blitz part but there's a sort of a cool down things like once you hit and your ball stops you have to wait like two seconds
3D的东西，有各种物理效果之类的。但其实是2D的。哦，抱歉，但当你击球时，球会往上飞，对吧？是的。哦，你的意思是，但所有的图形都是2D的。是的，所以它会，是的，所以它全是2D的，游戏就像是，你知道的，像关卡一样。洞可能直接在你站立的下方。你可能站在一个浮岛上，然后你的岛两边有两个岛，而下面还有另一个岛，位置更低，你需要从一个岛打到另一个岛，然后再从另一个岛打回中间，你努力争取第一个把球打进洞里。好吧，好了。所以它就像是“闪电战”的部分，但有一个所谓的冷却时间。一旦你击球并且球停下来了，你必须等待大约两秒钟
before you can hit again so you can't just like hit hit hit hit like you want to be strategic and so you know there's some some strategy goes into it and they try to match you with people who are about the same experience level as you um but anyways i played it just like a goofy casual game but you play until i think you get sort of a certain number i think you get three points for getting first and two points for second and i think you have to get uh what i, I don't even remember now, like eight points to win or something. To win that collection of matches. So it's like three or four holes.
才能再次击球，所以你不能像那样一直疯狂地击球。你希望讲究战略，所以，你知道的，其中包含了一些策略。他们会尽量把你匹配到和你的经验水平差不多的玩家。但无论如何，我把它当作一个愚蠢的休闲游戏来玩。你会一直玩到，我想你获得某个特定的分数，我想得第一名得三分，第二名得两分，你必须获得，我甚至记不清了，比如八分才能赢得比赛。赢得那一组比赛。所以大概是三四个洞。
And it plays in probably two minutes or something or three minutes. I've never timed it. Less than five minutes to play one iteration of this, which is a really good amount of time for me. Like, oh, oh okay i can sit down i can play this for like four or five minutes and i'm not hugely invested in it when i was playing pub g i always hated like you would play you would play for like 30 minutes and you get to the very end and then you just get shot because like somebody you know just it just happens
玩完一局大概只需要两分钟或者三分钟。我从来没计时过。玩完一轮不到五分钟，对我来说这是一个非常棒的时长。比如，哦，哦，我可以坐下来玩这个四五分钟，而且我不会投入太多的情感。当我玩《绝地求生》（PUBG）时，我总是讨厌那种，你会玩上整整30分钟，然后到了最后关头，你却被一枪爆头了，因为就像有人，你知道的，这种事有时就会发生，
sometimes but i felt very invested because it was so much time then you gotta play exactly and so i this isn't that way and i like it because of it it's a sort of very casual game but yeah warning it is is free to play it is on both ios and android though i will check it out man it sounds cool all right on to the topic topic is terminals and shells this actually came from a request from a person on Discord who has a Discord name, DoubleStep. I'm looking right now to see if they have a real name. No, it's okay. Just use that name. That's fine. That's good.
但我感觉自己投入了太多情感，因为花了那么多时间，然后你必须重新开始。确实如此。所以这个游戏不会那样，我因此而喜欢它。这是一个非常休闲的游戏。不过，提醒一下，它是免费游玩的。它在iOS和安卓平台上都有。我会去看看的，老兄，听起来很酷。好了，进入主题。主题是终端和Shell。这其实是一个Discord用户的请求，他在Discord上的名字叫DoubleStep。我正在看他是否有真实姓名。没有，没关系。就用那个名字。那挺好的。这很好。
Yeah, no. In real life, that's just a... That's what their real name is. It's a security card. Yeah. So he asked us to talk about terminal emulators. We'll do that, and we'll take it one step further. We'll talk about shells too. How about that? I think it was a good show topic.
是的，不。在现实生活中，那只是一个……那就是他的真名。这是一张安全卡。是的。所以他让我们谈谈终端模拟器。我们会谈的，而且我们会更进一步。我们也会谈谈Shell。觉得怎么样？我认为这是一个很好的节目主题。
It's, you know, this is one of those things where, I don't know if you're in the same boat, but for the longest time, I didn't spend any time at all on tooling. And a little bit can actually go a long way. Like having a decent terminal emulator set up, a decent shell, learning like the very basic keystrokes. Let's say you want to do like a find replace,
你知道的，这是那种情况，我不知道你是不是也一样，在很长一段时间里，我根本没有花任何时间在工具上。而稍微了解一点其实就能大有帮助。比如配置一个像样的终端模拟器，一个像样的Shell，学习一些非常基本的按键操作。假设你想做一个查找替换，
like being able to learn the keystrokes back can actually help a lot in productivity. And with that said, we'll jump into terminal emulators. So first we'll kind of, let me kind of explain kind of how this whole thing works. So you open up your computer and you type cmd.exe and hit enter. If you're on Windows, if you're on Mac, you go to the quick launch and you hit terminal. On Linux, same thing.
能够了解那些键盘快捷键实际上可以大大提高工作效率。话虽如此，我们直接切入终端模拟器。首先我们会，让我先解释一下这整个过程是如何运作的。你打开电脑，输入cmd.exe然后按回车。如果你在Windows上，如果你在Mac上，你去快速启动并输入terminal。在Linux上也是一样。
And a program pops up where you can enter some commands. That program, so that thing that renders that border, it's rendering the blinking cursor, that's the terminal emulator. What you see on the surface is a terminal emulator. Now when you hit let's say L on your keyboard, what's happening there is the terminal emulator program is capturing that keystroke and it's sending it to a shell. Now, you might have a terminal emulator that supports tabs or multiple windows. And so it could actually have multiple shells.
然后会弹出一个程序，你可以在其中输入一些命令。那个程序，也就是渲染那个边框、渲染闪烁光标的东西，就是终端模拟器。你在表面上看到的就是一个终端模拟器。现在，当你按下键盘上的L键时，发生的事情是终端模拟器程序捕获了那个按键，并将其发送给一个Shell。现在，你可能有一个支持标签页或多窗口的终端模拟器。因此它实际上可以有多个Shell。
Some of them even have panes. So you can actually have one window and it's split into two. So the left half of the screen might be running top. The right half of the screen is interactive. And so the terminal emulator might have one or more shells. When you hit L, it finds the right shell. That's the active shell, the one that is accepting your input. And it sends your L command to the shell program
其中一些甚至支持窗格。所以你实际上可以有一个窗口并把它分成两半。屏幕的左半部分可能在运行top命令。屏幕的右半部分是交互式的。因此，终端模拟器可能拥有一个或多个Shell。当你按下L键时，它会找到正确的Shell。也就是处于活动状态的Shell，那个正在接受你输入的Shell。它会将你的L命令发送给Shell程序。
right so when you start the terminal emulator it doesn't know anything about prompts or file systems or any of that what it does is it launches a program inside of it called the shell and what the shell does is the shell is responsible for you know connecting you to all those commands. So when you type ls, enter, the shell has to go and find the ls executable, run it, get some kind of output, and then it will send that back to the terminal emulator,
对吧？所以当你启动终端模拟器时，它对提示符、文件系统或任何这些东西一无所知。它所做的是在内部启动一个名为Shell的程序，而Shell的作用是，Shell负责将你连接到所有这些命令。所以当你输入ls并按回车时，Shell必须去找到ls可执行文件，运行它，获得某种输出，然后将其发送回终端模拟器，
which will render it on the screen. Does that make sense, Patrick? Yeah, I actually didn't quite know that, but that makes a lot of sense. Okay, cool. So now the terminal emulator and the shell are actually talking to each other. Now, most of the time it's very transparent. Like you press an L, the terminal emulator tells the shell, hey, L, and the shell says, okay, let's just echo that L back to the person because there's nothing for me to do yet. They haven't hit enter.
由终端模拟器将其渲染到屏幕上。这说得通吗，帕特里克？是的，我其实不太了解这个，但非常有道理。好的，太好了。所以现在终端模拟器和Shell实际上在互相通信。大多数时候，这是非常透明的。比如你按下一个L，终端模拟器告诉Shell：“嘿，是个L”，而Shell说：“好的，我们把那个L回显给这个人吧，因为我还无事可做。他们还没按回车呢。”
Terminal emulator says, okay, I'm going to draw an L because you told me to draw an L. But there's actually a protocol. Now, by default, the protocol is a pass-through. You type an L, you get an L. But there are what's called ANSI codes, A-N-S-I. I think, I don't know what that acronym stands for, but ANSI is, think of it as like the protocol.
终端模拟器说：“好的，我要画一个L，因为你叫我画一个L。”但实际上有一个协议。默认情况下，该协议是一个直通（pass-through）协议。你输入一个L，你就得到一个L。但存在所谓的ANSI代码，A-N-S-I。我想，我不知道这个缩写代表什么，但ANSI，你可以把它想象成一种协议。
So for example, if you do, if you remember your ASCII codes, you know, there's, I think it starts at, I want to say somewhere in the 20s or 30s. Do you remember what capital A is in the ASCII code? Capital A is, oh, man. I don't know what it is off the top of my head. 65 or hex 41.
所以举个例子，如果你做，如果你还记得你的ASCII码，你知道的，有，我想它是从，我想是从20多或30多开始的。你还记得ASCII码中的大写A是什么吗？大写A是，哦，天哪。我脑子里一下子想不起来了。65或者十六进制的41。
Oh, okay. But there's a number of codes that don't map to anything, right? And so I think... So hex 20 starts the printable command starting with space. Ah, okay. There you go. So before that, there's an opportunity there to use those extra codes to send some special information. And so there's a set of these codes that you can run in sequence,
哦，好吧。但有许多代码不映射到任何东西，对吧？所以我想……十六进制的20开始是可打印命令，从空格开始。啊，原来如此。就是这样。在此之前，有机会利用这些额外的代码来发送一些特殊信息。所以有一组这样的代码你可以按顺序运行，
and that's going to tell the terminal emulator, hey, I'm going to do something special. So these letters that you're going to see next, they're not just regular letters you need to draw. They're commands to tell you to act a certain way. And you can do a variety of things with that. You can actually move the cursor around. So you could tell the terminal emulator, hey, I want you to take the cursor and move it to row three, even if you might be on row 30,000 or something like that. Well, I guess your screen's not that big.
这会告诉终端模拟器：“嘿，我要做一些特别的事情。”所以接下来你看到的这些字母，不仅仅是需要你绘制的普通字母。它们是告诉你以某种特定方式行事的命令。你可以用它做各种各样的事情。你实际上可以移动光标。所以你可以告诉终端模拟器：“嘿，我希望你把光标移动到第三行”，即使你当前可能在第30,000行左右。嗯，我想你的屏幕没那么大。
If you're on row, I don't know, 20, you just go to row three. You could also change colors. So if you've ever run a shell command, or sorry, you've ever run a command line command and it actually displays colors on your terminal, those are special ANSI sequences. So that's part of that protocol. The shell is running your program. Your program is telling the shell,
如果你在，我不知道，第20行，你直接去第三行。你还可以更改颜色。所以如果你曾经运行过shell命令，或者抱歉，你曾经运行过一个命令行命令，它实际上在你的终端上显示了颜色，那些就是特殊的ANSI序列。所以那是该协议的一部分。Shell正在运行你的程序。你的程序正在告诉Shell：
hey, send this special code and then to turn the text to red. That shell is telling your terminal emulator to do that. Your terminal emulator says, OK, for now on all the letters I see, they're all going to be red. And then you say hello world. And then hopefully if you're if you're if you're nice to the person who comes after you, change it back to white and then you exit the program, right?
“嘿，发送这个特殊的代码，然后把文本变成红色。”那个Shell正在告诉你的终端模拟器这样做。你的终端模拟器说：“好的，从现在开始我看到的所有的字母，它们全都要是红色的。”然后你说了句“hello world”。然后希望如果你对后来人还算友好，再把它改回白色，然后你退出程序，对吧？
There's actually a bunch of really crazy ANSI commands that are supported by most terminal emulators. You can actually render an image to the terminal, which is pretty wild. I mean, imagine you're just in command.exe, and all of a sudden an image shows up. It's actually doable. And yeah, a bunch of cool things that are possible there.
实际上有许多非常疯狂的ANSI命令是大多数终端模拟器支持的。你甚至可以在终端中渲染一张图片，这相当疯狂。我的意思是，想象一下你正处于command.exe中，突然弹出了一张图片。这其实是可行的。是的，那里还有一堆很酷的可能性。
You can ring the system bell. That's actually pretty frustrating. If you've ever done cat on a binary file, what that's going to do is it's going to render all of those raw bytes of data to the terminal. And so that's why if you ever cat a binary file and weird stuff starts happening to the terminal, it's because of those ANSI codes so you know it's this binary file
你可以触发系统铃声。这其实相当令人沮丧。如果你曾在二进制文件上执行过cat命令，那么它会做的是将该文件的所有原始字节数据渲染到终端上。这就是为什么如果你对二进制文件执行cat命令，终端开始出现奇怪的事情，罪魁祸首就是这些ANSI代码。所以你知道这个二进制文件
is just holding arbitrary data and your terminal emulator is trying to sorry your shell is trying to interpret that and send it to the terminal emulator your terminal emulator is just drawing all these weird symbols and all of a sudden just coincidentally it gets you know an ass an ansi code to ring the system bell or to change the color to red or something like that and uh so that's that's why it's usually bad news usually your terminal is
只是保存了任意数据，而你的终端模拟器正试图，抱歉，你的Shell正试图解释它并将其发送给终端模拟器，你的终端模拟器只是在绘制所有这些奇怪的符号，然后突然之间，巧合的是，它收到了一个，你知道的，用于触发系统铃声或将颜色更改为红色的ANSI代码，诸如此类。所以，这就是为什么这通常是个坏消息。通常你的终端
just hosed if you do that um so that's in a nutshell how that that all works do you have any questions, Patrick? Does that make sense? So the terminal emulator, now I'm going to botch up the part I understand. So the idea is to replicate that this used to be some mainframe and your computer would send some command over the network link to the computer. So you had sort of a dumb, not a computer like we have today,
如果你那样做了，基本上就彻底瘫痪了。所以简而言之，这就是这一切的工作原理。你有任何问题吗，帕特里克？这说得通吗？所以终端模拟器，现在我要把我理解的那部分搞砸了。所以这个想法是为了复制过去的那种大型机，你的电脑会通过网络链接向那台计算机发送一些命令。所以你拥有的是某种哑终端（dumb terminal），不是我们今天拥有的那种电脑，
but you would have some really dumb electronics that didn't know anything. And so when you typed a character on the keyboard, it literally needed to sort of send the information that that key represented to a computer somewhere else in order to know what to do with that character. And this is why you said that sort of like echo thing. So like the idea is like I typed the letter L
而是一些一无所知的真正简陋的电子设备。所以当你在键盘上打出一个字符时，它字面上需要将该键代表的信息发送到其他地方的某台计算机，以便知道如何处理那个字符。这就是为什么你刚才说那种“回显”的事情。所以这个想法就像是我在键盘上敲下了字母L，
and my keyboard and my screen like aren't connected to each other. Like the keyboard sends the message to the other room and then it sends back, Oh, Hey screen, you need to print out that letter onto this, this location or whatever. And yeah,
然后我的键盘和我的屏幕并没有直接连在一起。就像键盘把消息发送到另一个房间，然后它发回：“哦，嘿，屏幕，你需要把那个字母打印到这个位置或别的什么地方。”而且，
exactly. I mean, that's the history of it. Yep. And so, so that history of all, and it's like what you're saying, which is like,
完全正确。我的意思是，这就是它的历史。是的。所以所有这一切的历史，就像你所说的那样，也就是，
well now we don't send it necessarily over the network, but you just send it to sort of a local running process. Yeah, exactly. There you got it. Yeah. And so the terminal emulator invokes the shell as the first thing it does if that's what you have your environment set up to do. So you set what shell you want to run,
嗯，现在我们不一定通过网络发送它了，你只是把它发送给本地运行的进程。是的，完全正确。你抓住了要领。是的。所以终端模拟器做的第一件事就是fork（分叉）Shell，如果你的环境设置成这样的话。所以你设置你想运行哪个Shell，
and it runs that program as the first thing it does. Yeah, exactly. you set like what shell you want to run and it runs that that program as the first thing it does yep yeah exactly so the first thing terminal emulator does is it forks um it forks that uh that shell and the reason why it forks it is if you do something bad and destroy the shell you don't lose the whole screen the whole app um and then yeah just through through inter-process communication it's going to send those letters to the shell and it's going to get back, um, whatever the shell wants to send it. Okay. So the terminal, I mean, there's like basically all for like handling input and output and
它做的第一件事就是运行那个程序。是的，完全正确。所以终端模拟器做的第一件事是fork，它fork了那个Shell，而之所以要fork它，是因为如果你做了什么不好的事情并且搞垮了Shell，你不会丢失整个屏幕或整个应用程序。然后，是的，通过进程间通信，它会将那些字母发送给Shell，并且会收到，嗯，Shell想要发送给它的任何内容。好的。所以终端，我的意思是，基本上所有的作用都是为了处理输入输出和
rendering the like results. That's right. And it's also a shell manager, like tabs and all of that. Oh, sure. So, okay. Yeah. So it has many different shells. It has to know which one is active based on if you
渲染结果。没错。它也是一个Shell管理器，负责标签页和所有这些。哦，当然。所以，嗯。是的。所以它有许多不同的Shell。它必须根据你是否
click over or if you, what is it on Mac? I think it's command shift bracket moves you over to the next tab or something. And so that the terminal emulator has to intercept certain keystrokes and has to know that that's actually for me, that's not for the shell and all of that. Okay. So when you, how does it interact interact and we'll talk about shells in a second because then it's up next so how does the terminal emulator interact if you run something like tmux or something that allow our screen where you yep that makes sense like what is it so yeah yeah so that's that's a pretty deep question so by default no it's fine by default like Tmux and screen are running inside the shell. So one thing, the terminal emulator in the shell,
点击切换或者，在Mac上是什么来着？我想是command + shift + 方括号把你切换到下一个标签页之类的。因此终端模拟器必须拦截某些按键，并且必须知道那是给它自己的，而不是给Shell的，诸如此类。好的。所以当你在，它是如何交互的，我们一会儿再谈Shell，因为接下来就要讲。那么，如果你运行诸如tmux之类的东西，或者允许我们使用screen之类的内容，终端模拟器是如何与之交互的？是的，这说得通。那是什么？
sorry, the terminal emulator is constantly telling the shell the size of the screen in characters. So if you resize the window, the terminal emulator actually tells the shell, hey, now your operating space is 100 characters by 40 characters. So the way Tmux works is Tmux knows that size. And so when it renders a bar at the bottom, and when you split the screen in half and things like that, Tmux is using that information.
所以，是的，这是一个相当深奥的问题。默认情况下，不，没关系。默认情况下，像Tmux和screen是在Shell内部运行的。所以有一件事，终端模拟器和Shell，抱歉，终端模拟器不断地以字符为单位向Shell告知屏幕的大小。所以如果你调整窗口大小，终端模拟器实际上会告诉Shell：“嘿，现在你的操作空间是100个字符乘40个字符。”所以Tmux的工作方式是Tmux知道这个尺寸。因此，当它在底部渲染一个状态栏，当你把屏幕切成两半之类的时候，Tmux就在使用这些信息。
But other than that, it's completely living in the context of the shell. It doesn't know anything about the terminal emulator. And same thing for screen. Now, there is a catch. There's a special mode in Tmux called Control Center, which is actually a completely different app. It's just made by the same person who made Tmux called control center which is actually a completely different app it's just uh made by the same person who made tmux um and and if you have tmux control center that only works with iterm2 the terminal emulator and that actually um uses again uses this ansSI system, ANSI escape code system,
除此之外，它完全生活在Shell的上下文中。它对终端模拟器一无所知。screen也是如此。不过，有一个例外。Tmux中有一种特殊模式叫Control Center（控制中心），它实际上是一个完全不同的应用程序。它只是由制作Tmux的同一个人制作的，叫做Control Center，它实际上是一个完全不同的应用程序，它只是，嗯，由制作Tmux的同一个人制作的，嗯，如果你使用了Tmux Control Center，那它只适用于iTerm2终端模拟器，并且它实际上，再次强调，使用了这个ANSI系统，ANSI转义码系统。
to send special commands that only iTerm2 understands. And so using this tmux control center, tmux can actually even move the windows around and things like that. So if you wanted to write a program to create four tabs, you couldn't do it because the shell, there's no way for the shell to tell the terminal emulator to do that. Unless you're using iTerm2. iTerm2 has that built into the protocol, but it's not standard. Okay. Yeah. So, so jumping into terminal emulators, like some of the popular ones, you know, on Windows, you're usually stuck
发送只有 iTerm2 才能理解的特殊命令。因此，通过这个 tmux 控制中心，tmux 甚至可以移动窗口之类的。所以如果你想写一个程序来创建四个选项卡，你是做不到的，因为 shell 没有办法告诉终端模拟器那样做。除非你在使用 iTerm2。iTerm2 的协议中内置了这一点，但它不是标准的。好吧。是的。所以，说到终端模拟器，比如一些流行的，你知道的，在 Windows 上，你通常会被困在
with terminal emulators that were terrible, to be completely honest. There's cmd.exe and PowerShell. Both of these, I mean, I'm sure I'm going to get hate mail for this, but let's be honest, these are terrible. These are terrible, terrible terminal emulators. You know, with command.exe, if you click, it kind of highlights, but it does this weird box highlighting. Have you seen this? No. So if you want, let's say you have a line that starts from after your prompt and kind of ends in the first or second character of the next line.
说实话，那些糟糕的终端模拟器上。有 cmd.exe 和 PowerShell。这两个——我的意思是，我确信我会因此收到辱骂邮件——但说实话，它们真的很糟糕。这些都是非常非常糟糕的终端模拟器。你知道，使用 command.exe 时，如果你点击它，它会高亮显示，但它会做这种奇怪的方框高亮。你见过这个吗？没有。所以如果你愿意，比方说你有一行，从提示符后面开始，到下一行的第一个或第二个字符结束。
You can't actually select that text because when you select in command, it selects like a box. It's like a drag, like a lasso. That's one of the reasons. I mean, there's no tabs. There's no multiple windows. It's just not very good. I don't think it even supports colors. Actually, PowerShell does. But now Microsoft lately has been on an absolute tear. I mean, they have been killing it. They really, someone kind of, I mean, maybe a lot of people attribute it to the new CEO. But they really have kind of swallowed their pride. They know what they've been good at, what they've been bad at. And they went and rewrote an entire terminal emulator from
你其实无法选中那段文本，因为在 command 中进行选择时，它的选择方式就像一个方框。就像拖动一样，像个套索。这就是原因之一。我的意思是，它没有标签页。没有多窗口。它就是不太好。我觉得它甚至不支持颜色。实际上，PowerShell 支持。但现在微软最近简直势不可挡。我是说，他们太棒了。真的，有人——我的意思是，也许很多人把它归功于新 CEO。但他们真的有点放下了身段。他们知道自己擅长什么，不擅长什么。他们去从头
scratch, which they're calling Windows Terminal. I tried to compile it yesterday and I couldn't. But part of it is I don't know what I'm doing. I don't do development on Windows. So I took my gaming PC and tried to build it and I got stuck. But they are going to release a binary in a few months. And so I'm really looking forward to that. The videos look very appealing. It looks very similar to what we have on Linux and Mac. So I'll talk about those. On Linux, your choices are gterminal or console, depending on whether you're using GNOME or KDE. There are alternatives, of course. There's RXVT, there's Terminator.
重写了一个完整的终端模拟器，他们称之为 Windows Terminal。我昨天尝试编译它，但没成功。但部分原因是我不知道自己在做什么。我不在 Windows 上进行开发。所以我拿我的游戏 PC 尝试构建它，然后就卡住了。不过他们几个月后会发布一个二进制文件。所以我真的很期待那个。这些视频看起来非常吸引人。它看起来和我们在 Linux 和 Mac 上拥有的非常相似。所以我来谈谈那些。在 Linux 上，你的选择是 gnome-terminal 或 konsole，这取决于你使用的是 GNOME 还是 KDE。当然还有其他选择。有 RXVT，有 Terminator。
I mean, the list goes on and on and on, but those are the two big ones. If you're on OS X, then you're using either terminal, the built-in terminal, or you're using iTerm2. I'm a big fan of iTerm2. Which one do you use, Patrick? Yeah, I do use iTerm2. Yeah, yeah. iTerm2 is, in my opinion, is much better. Definitely worth the download. As far as other terminals, there is actually a cross-platform terminal called Hyper. It sounds really appealing because you could just learn Hyper and now it doesn't
我的意思是，名单没完没了，但这是两个大头。如果你在使用 OS X，那么你要么使用终端（内置终端），要么使用 iTerm2。我是 iTerm2 的超级粉丝。你用哪一个，帕特里克（Patrick）？是的，我确实用 iTerm2。对，对。在我看来，iTerm2 要好得多。绝对值得下载。至于其他终端，实际上有一个名为 Hyper 的跨平台终端。它听起来非常吸引人，因为你只需要学习 Hyper，现在无论你是在
matter whether you're on Windows, Mac, whatever. But it's just not very good yet. It's still a little bit immature. I think eventually that's kind of where things will go. It's built on Electron and all of that. So that seems to be where desktop apps are headed. So keep an eye out on Hyper. I think the website's hyper.js. Sorry, that's the name of it. I think the website might be hyper.is, I think. But if you look up Hyper Terminal, you'll find it right away.
Windows、Mac 还是别的什么系统上都无所谓了。但它现在还不是很好。它仍然有点不成熟。我想最终事情大概会朝那个方向发展。它是基于 Electron 等技术构建的。所以这似乎是桌面应用程序的发展方向。因此，请关注 Hyper。我想网站是 hyper.js。抱歉，那是它的名字。我想网站可能是 hyper.is。不过如果你搜索 Hyper Terminal，你马上就能找到。
That might be where things are heading, but it's still a little too early for that. So you talked about the terminal emulator and then it talks to the shell. And so the shell is what's responsible for sort of like doing the things you talked about the the terminal emulator and then it talks to the shell and so the shell is what's responsible for sort of like doing the things you think about being on the the command line so if you you know like you were saying before like i typed the letter l and i typed the letter s and i pushed return that's the shell's job to invoke the program in the file system called ls to list a directory um yeah and so the if you had a
这可能是未来的发展方向，但现在还为时过早。所以你谈到了终端模拟器，然后它会与 shell 进行通信。因此，shell 负责执行你所想的关于——终端模拟器然后它会与 shell 进行通信，因此 shell 负责执行那些你认为属于命令行范畴的事情，比如，正如你之前所说，我键入了字母 l，我键入了字母 s，然后我按下了回车键，这就是 shell 的工作，它会调用文件系统中名为 ls 的程序来列出目录。嗯，是的，如果你有一个
like really terrible shell it wouldn't know how to do that and then also like as simple as that sounds like i was thinking about this uh you know kind of earlier there's actually a lot that goes into that so um people always talk about like using linux or getting started or like programming and i forget how many things you have to learn to sit down and do this like like jason was oh i'm trying to compile this shell or whatever and all the things to do but for me it i it's somewhat hard to remember now like all of the things i didn't used to know like you needed to cd into this directory and then you need to ls and then there's a path so if i try to run a program like LS, like the shell needs to know where that lives at. And it knows where that lives at
非常糟糕的 shell，它会不知道该怎么做听起来很简单，但我之前考虑过这个问题，嗯，其实这背后有很多门道。所以，人们总是谈论使用 Linux、入门或编程，我常常忘记你要坐下来做这些需要学习多少东西，就像杰森（Jason）说的，哦，我正试图编译这个 shell 或别的什么，以及所有要做的事情。但对我来说，现在有点难记住我以前不知道的所有事情——比如你需要 cd 到这个目录，然后你需要 ls，然后还有一个路径。所以如果我想运行一个像 LS 这样的程序，shell 需要知道它存在于哪里。它之所以知道它存在于哪里，
because of this environment variable called the path. But what's an environment variable? How do I change it? How do I set it? And these things are like by convention somewhat similar across shells, but they don't have to be. So most people are used to running the bash shell,
是因为这个名为 path 的环境变量。但什么是环境变量？我该如何更改它？我该如何设置它？这些事情按惯例在各个 shell 之间有点相似，但并非必须如此。所以大多数人习惯于运行 bash shell，
the born again shell, which was the successor to that, just the shell SH or the born shell. And so there was a collection of these kind of shells. And I guess I don't want to say one out because someone will email us and tell us that that's not how it is at all. Well, but there was SH and CSH. That's what I was going to say. So there were csh ksh um yeah there's like a whole variety of these all with various ways of interacting and they
也就是 Bourne Again shell，它是 shell SH 或 Bourne shell 的后继者。因此，有一系列这类 shell。我想我不想随便说出一个，否则有人会发邮件告诉我们情况根本不是这样的。好吧，但有 SH 和 CSH。这就是我要说的。所以有 csh、kash、嗯，有各种各样的 shell，它们都有各种交互方式，而且它们
mostly work with each other and i guess there's like some sort of conventions and um posix sort of like guidelines for how to do stuff um but like how to write a for loop would be different between them how environment variables work would be for loop would be different between them how environment variables work would be you know kind of different between them if you did piping between programs that's like a function of the shell so if you ever did like jason said if you ever output a binary file the cat so just cat the file and it you know sort of prints the whole file to your screen to the terminal emulator from the shell it it sends all the ascii characters to the terminal emulator from the shell it sends all the ascii characters to the terminal emulator to display them some of which are ringing bells and some are changing colors
大多能彼此协作，我想还有一些惯例和 POSIX 规范来指导如何做事。但是，例如，如何在它们之间编写 for 循环会有所不同，环境变量如何工作也会——for 循环会有所不同，环境变量如何工作也会因它们而异。如果你在程序之间使用管道，那是 shell 的一项功能。所以如果你像杰森说的那样，输出一个二进制文件，用 cat 命令——直接 cat 这个文件，它就会（某种程度上）把整个文件打印到你的屏幕上，从 shell 发送到终端模拟器，它会把所有的 ASCII 字符从 shell 发送到终端模拟器来显示它们，其中有些字符会触发响铃，有些会改变颜色，
or who knows what um and so when that interaction happens if you did like cat and then and bash and nzsh and a lot of others there's this vertical line the pipe symbol and then you know you did the word count program wc and then dash l for count the number of lines you know the the handling of executing the one command taking its output from the sort of the the standard out and putting it into the standard end of the next program like that's the function of the shell that's what the shell is doing and how that works is you know like i said sort of by convention and by these standards but ultimately you could just write a shell that did whatever you want it could use the dot instead of the pipe command that might be confusing yeah but it could do that um and things might break in various strange ways and it often does so if you ever end up running a different shell, sometimes things don't work. So one of the instances is like we've talked about
或者谁知道呢。所以当这种交互发生时，如果你像在 bash、zsh 和许多其他 shell 中那样使用 cat，会有一个垂直线，即管道符号，然后（你知道的）使用字数统计程序 wc，再加上用于计算行数的 -L 参数。你知道的，处理执行一个命令，将其输出从标准输出（standard out）获取并放入下一个程序的标准输入（standard in）中，这就是 shell 的功能，这就是 shell 正在做的事情。它的工作原理正如我所说，是通过惯例和这些标准实现的，但归根结底，你完全可以编写一个做你想做任何事情的 shell，它可以用点号而不是管道命令，这可能会让人困惑，是的，但它确实可以做到。事情可能会以各种奇怪的方式崩溃，而且通常也确实会崩溃。因此，如果你最终运行了不同的 shell，有时事情就行不通了。所以其中的一个例子就像我们在
on the show before, oh, my ZSH, and the ZSH shell, which actually is pretty old, but oh, my ZSH is a little newer, and how it adds a lot of really awesome things, which you can talk about in a second. But one of the things is, I believe it's how environment arrays in environment variables is different between the two. And so if you have a script that worked in Bash and you try to run it in ZSH, how they store arrays isn't a just SH shell level feature, but it's like a Bash feature that people get used to. And if you try to run it in ZSH, it won't work. And you can run into incompatibilities between these two also like if you run a child shell as part of a command like you're running a script and it sets environment variables do those
节目中讨论过的，oh-my-zsh，以及 zsh shell，它其实相当古老，但 oh-my-zsh 要新一些，以及它是如何添加许多真正棒的功能的，你可以稍后讨论。但其中之一是，我相信两者之间环境变量中数组的处理方式是不同的。因此，如果你有一个在 Bash 中起作用的脚本，并试图在 ZSH 中运行它，它们存储数组的方式不仅仅是 SH shell 级别的特性，而是一个人们已经习惯的 Bash 特性。如果你试图在 ZSH 中运行它，它就行不通了。你可能会遇到这两者之间的不兼容问题，就像作为命令一部分运行子 shell 时那样——比如你运行一个脚本，它设置了环境变量，这些
environment variables propagate back up to the parent shell or not like all of those things are conventions that sort of end up getting handled by the shell but it's mostly the interaction between through the terminal emulator to the shell is your ability to run all these programs either programs you've built or programs that the system knows about and giving those programs the paths they need like where the the dynamic libraries live so on a mac os that would be dialibs on linux it'd be so some windows It'd be SOs on Windows. It'd be DLLs. Uh, I don't even know people do that in windows that way, but like, and there's other ones that's like setting up that environment is the job of the shell. Yep. And so that totally,
环境变量会传播回父 shell 吗？诸如此类的事情都是最终由 shell 处理的惯例，但它主要是在终端模拟器和 shell 之间的交互，让你能够运行所有这些程序，无论是你构建的程序还是系统知道的程序，并为这些程序提供它们所需的路径——比如动态库的存放位置。在 macOS 上，那将是 dylibs，在 Linux 上将是 so，在 Windows 上将是 DLL。呃，我甚至不知道人们在 Windows 上是不是那样做的，但是，还有其他的，比如设置该环境是 shell 的工作。是的。所以完全，
oops, that command prompt that you see, um, is, is another function of the shell. And, you know, back in the day, I didn't know it could do cool things um but today it feels like i see people i go to other people's computers at work and talk and they've got all sorts of crazy things displayed and some of them are you know oh my zsh theme some of them are even just things you can do in bash um but they can show like what git branch you're on so mine will tell me if i'm in a you know i'm in this python virtual environment on this git branch and you know let me know you know kind of my current state of that window because i have multiple open um and that's really useful being able to tab complete is super helpful and one of the things i like about zsh that i think does work in bash but it doesn't work as well
哦，你看到的那个命令提示符，嗯，是 shell 的另一个功能。而且，过去我并不知道它可以做这么酷的事情，但今天我觉得我看到人们——我去公司里其他人的电脑前聊天，他们展示了各种疯狂的东西，其中一些是 oh-my-zsh 主题，其中一些甚至只是你可以在 bash 中做的事情，但它们可以显示你处于哪个 git 分支。所以我的会告诉我，如果我在一个（你知道的）这个 python 虚拟环境中，在这个 git 分支上，并且（你知道的）让我了解该窗口的当前状态，因为我打开了多个窗口。这真的很有用，能够进行 Tab 补全超级有帮助。我喜欢 zsh 的一点是——我认为 bash 中也有，但没那么好用——
is the fuzzy matching so oh yeah the fuzzy matching is so much better yeah i love the fuzzy matching and also like in in in oh my zsh configured you know you can double tap the tab and it'll give you the ability to use your cursors to select the thing you want to complete to so yeah so just to give an example of this let's say you know on linux it's all case sensitive so let's say you have a folder called, you know, my picks and P is capitalized. And so you do LS, my picks, and you don't capitalize the P. You do MYP and then hit tab. It won't do anything because there's nothing.
就是模糊匹配。哦，对，模糊匹配好太多了。是的，我超爱模糊匹配。而且在 oh-my-zsh 配置中，你可以双击 Tab，它就会让你能够使用光标来选择你想要补全的对象。所以，举个例子，假设在 Linux 中它是区分大小写的，假设你有一个名为 myPicks 的文件夹，其中 P 是大写的。然后你执行 `LS myPicks`，但你没有将 P 大写。你输入 `MYP` 然后按 Tab。它不会做任何事情，因为没有这样的东西。
There's no folder like that. I know. Sorry. With the fuzzy matching, it will actually just match it. But now let's say you you do something where the fuzzy matching matches it, but it's not quite what you wanted. So let's say you have my pets and my picks and you do M.Y.P. You hit tab and you get my pets. You can actually hit tab again and it will, yeah, give you this really cool menu where you can kind of hit tab to cycle through the menu. And that's configurable.
没有这样的文件夹。我知道。抱歉。有了模糊匹配，它实际上就会匹配到。但现在，假设你做了一些事情，模糊匹配匹配到了它，但并不是你想要的。比方说，你有 `myPets` 和 `myPicks`，你输入了 `m.y.p`。你按 Tab，然后得到了 `myPets`。你实际上可以再次按 Tab，然后它就会——是的，给你提供这个非常酷的菜单，你可以通过按 Tab 在菜单中循环切换。这是可配置的。
And, you know, people have very elaborate configurations and not elaborate configurations. But as Jason, I guess, was pointing out earlier, like spending time on your tooling, like making sure that you have an environment that suits you kind of sometimes feels like a waste. And some people obviously take it to an extreme where they spend more time sort of like making it, tricking it out and making it look cool than actual like functionally improving what they're doing.
而且，人们会有非常复杂的配置和不那么复杂的配置。但正如杰森刚才所指出的，花时间在你的工具上，确保你拥有一个适合自己的环境，有时感觉像是一种浪费。显然，有些人将其推向了极端，他们花在修饰它、让它看起来很酷上的时间，比实际在功能上改善他们正在做的事情的时间还要多。
But spending some amount of time and getting something that works well for you really does make things faster. And learning enough shell commands that you can get by and get stuff done and do simple scripting really does get you out of a lot of binds. Because it is often much faster, as sort of Jason was indicating, to write sort of like a one-line Linux script than to write a Python script that would be really overcomplicated to do it. Or try to figure out how to do it in C++, I guess. All of those would be pretty hard to do. So learning enough of it
但花上一段时间，弄出一个对你很管用的东西，确实能让事情变得更快。掌握足够的 shell 命令，让你能够应付过去、完成工作并编写简单的脚本，确实能帮你摆脱很多困境。正如杰森所暗示的那样，编写一个单行的 Linux 脚本通常比编写一个过于复杂的 Python 脚本要快得多。或者试图弄清楚如何在 C++ 中做到这一点，我想。所有这些做起来都相当困难。所以学习足够的知识
to get you out of the easiest examples is a desirable feature. But there's other kinds of shells as well. So we mentioned like CSH, there was KSH. These are ones like, I personally never used them before I've done them like launched them by accident and then realized like I don't know what I'm doing I've done that too
来帮你摆脱最简单的例子是一个可取的特性。不过也有其他类型的 shell。所以我们提到了 CSH，还有 KSH。这些是我个人以前从未使用过的，我曾经不小心启动过它们，然后意识到——我不知道自己在做什么。我也做过那样的傻事。
but I will say the other thing is that if you want to write the sort of I don't know maybe like the best way but if you don't know what other people are going to be using it's often at the beginning of your script, you do the, what is that?
但我必须说，另一件事是，如果你想编写某种——我不知道，也许是最好的方式——但如果你不知道其他人会使用什么，通常在脚本的开头，你会使用那个，那叫什么？
They call it like the shebang, right? Like pound, pound exclamation point. And then the program that should execute to launch the script. And if you do sort of slash bin slash sh instead of like bin slash bash, and actually make sure your script is compatible with the sort of just the sh shell the the kind
他们称之为 shebang，对吧？就像井号、井号感叹号。然后是应该执行以启动脚本的程序。如果你使用的是 `/bin/sh` 而不是 `/bin/bash`，并且实际上确保你的脚本与 sh shell 兼容——那种
of simplest shell then you have more likelihood that it's going to be portable to other things if you don't do that it's just very likely you end up running it as a bash script or a zsh script or whatever your current shell is yeah yeah that's right as long as you do that shebang, then even if someone's in bash, but your shebang is ZSH, it'll switch over to ZSH to run the script. And it's possible they don't have that installed because it doesn't come installed on all systems. Yeah, that's true.
最简单的 shell——那么你的脚本更有可能移植到其他东西上。如果你不这样做，它最终很有可能作为 bash 脚本、zsh 脚本或你当前使用的任何 shell 脚本运行。对，对，没错。只要你使用了那个 shebang，那么即使某人身处 bash 中，但你的 shebang 是 ZSH，它也会切换到 ZSH 来运行该脚本。而且可能他们并没有安装那个，因为它并非预装在所有系统上。是的，确实如此。
Yeah. Yeah. But that's easier than a person runs it and they get some really bizarre error. Yeah, I've had that happen a lot. Most people don't actually specify. They just name it dot sh and they don't actually uh do the shebang at the top um so be kind so the other popular ones we've talked about bash which is the default on many uh
对。是的。但这总比一个人运行它却得到一些极其怪异的错误要好。是的，我经常遇到这种情况。大多数人实际上并不指定。他们只是将它命名为 `.sh`，实际上并没有在顶部做 shebang。所以，态度好一点。我们讨论过另一个流行的 bash，它在许多系统上是默认的。
i think it's a default on mac os i believe it's the default on most Linux distributions. We talked about ZSH with the OhMyZSH sort of like configuration is really nice. The other one I know some amount of people around me use is Phish. Now, Phish is a little different in that it does a lot of really cool things, and it's much newer than a lot of the other ones, but it doesn't have full posix compatibility so they decided that some of the things that posix chose to do were wrong or outdated and so they've chosen to break posix compatibility and trying to be a more understandable shell so they try to give better errors they try to do the thing that's more expected than the thing that's more compliant um but it i do find that if
我想它是 macOS 的默认设置，我相信它也是大多数 Linux 发行版的默认设置。我们讨论了带有 OhMyZSH 配置的 ZSH，真的很棒。我知道我周围有一些人使用的另一个是 Fish。现在，Fish 有点不同，因为它做了很多非常酷的事情，而且它比许多其他 shell 要新得多，但它没有完全的 POSIX 兼容性。所以他们决定 POSIX 选择做的一些事情是错误的或过时的，因此他们选择打破 POSIX 兼容性，并试图成为一个更易于理解的 shell。所以他们试图提供更好的错误提示，他们试图做那些更符合预期而不是更符合标准的事情。不过，我确实发现，如果你
you're in a shared environment where other people are writing shell scripts that you're supposed to run for like configuring your development environment or something, and you run Phish, you're often going to be having to make changes yourself to get it all to work because it is far less compatible than the Bash and ZSH.
身处一个共享环境中，其他人正在编写你需要运行的 shell 脚本来配置你的开发环境或类似的东西，而你运行的是 Fish，你通常必须自己做一些修改才能让它全部工作，因为它远没有 Bash 和 ZSH 那样兼容。
But the people who use it just say it like is totally worth it i've never stuck with it long enough to try so i can't say yep i'm in exactly the same boat where even things like setting variables doesn't work the same way i think in fish it's like let x equal three but everyone else you just say export x equal three and um and so yeah it's just too non-standard for me to get into it but um i also know some people who absolutely swear by it so it might be worth trying trying for like a month and then seeing how it goes um one thing if you regardless of what shell you use if you write any type of script um it's really good to have shell check. So shell check is, uh, a, a program, which it's like a static analysis tool for shell
但使用它的人都说完全值得。我从来没有坚持使用它足够长的时间去尝试，所以我不能说。是的，我的情况完全一样，甚至连设置变量的方式都不一样。我想在 Fish 中是像 `let x equal three` 这样的，但其他人你只需要说 `export x equal three`。所以，是的，它对我的胃口来说太不标准了。不过，我也知道有些人对它顶礼膜拜，所以也许值得尝试一个月，看看进展如何。有一件事是，无论你使用什么 shell，如果你编写任何类型的脚本，使用 ShellCheck 真的很好。所以 ShellCheck 是一个程序，它就像是 shell 脚本的静态分析工具。
scripts. Um, so you can get it as like a Emax, um, package. Um, most, you know, if you're using Visual Studio code, there's a, there's a plugin. It's very ubiquitous. Um, and it will tell you things that are a little bit dangerous. Like one of the things that really burns people is handling file names. And, you know, most of the time it's okay, but you want to be robust, especially if the file names are programmatically generated. So if the file name has a dash in it and you don't handle that file name in the right way, you can end up causing some issues.
所以你可以把它作为一个 Emacs 插件来获取。大多数人——如果你使用的是 Visual Studio Code，也有插件。它非常无处不在。它会告诉你一些有点危险的事情。比如真正让人头疼的事情之一就是处理文件名。而且，大多数时候都没问题，但你需要做到健壮，尤其是当文件名是以编程方式生成的时候。因此，如果文件名中包含破折号，而你没有以正确的方式处理该文件名，你最终可能会导致一些问题。
So for example, you try to remove the file, but it's actually if the file is like JSON-R, you remove the file and then it interprets the dash R as a switch, and then it removes everything in that directory. And there's just weird things that can happen there. And so you have to be good about sort of escaping the strings correctly and things like that. And shell check will like be very clear about it. You'll just say, oh, you know, use the double quote.
例如，你试图删除该文件，但实际上如果文件名类似于 `-r`，你删除了该文件，然后它将 `-r` 解释为一个开关（选项），然后它就会删除该目录中的所有内容。那里可能会发生一些奇怪的事情。所以你必须善于正确转义字符串之类的。ShellCheck 会对此非常明确。它会直接说，哦，使用双引号。
It should be a single quote here. Things like that, because there's a lot of nuance there. And I definitely don't claim to be an expert, but I rely pretty heavily on shell check to just make sure it's doing the right thing. I didn't know about that. I am going to be doing that, trying that out tomorrow. Cool, yeah, you can shell check your entire repo. I bet you'll find hundreds of issues.
这里应该用单引号。诸如此类的事情，因为这里有很多微妙之处。我绝对不敢自称是专家，但我非常依赖 ShellCheck 来确保它在做正确的事情。我以前不知道这个。我明天就要去试试这个。酷，是的，你可以对你的整个代码库运行 shell check。我敢打赌你会发现数百个问题。
I don't think I'm gonna like what I find. Yeah, no, I mean, it's only, you have to have special characters in the file name, which is very rare. Actually, dash is not that rare. Dash can easily happen. But some of the other ones are pretty rare, like star, asterisk, and stuff like that. But yeah, those are terminal and shell.
我想我不会喜欢我发现的东西。是的，不，我的意思是，只有当你的文件名中有特殊字符时才会有，这非常罕见。其实破折号并不那么罕见。破折号很容易出现。但其他一些符号相当罕见，比如星号、星号之类的。不过，好了，这就是终端和 shell。
So double step. I hope you enjoyed this. This is a great suggestion, actually. Thank you for suggesting this. We had a set of, I mean, we have a list of ideas, but that one was just immediately really useful, especially it was timely because the Windows Terminal was just announced May 2nd.
所以，双步。希望你们喜欢这个。这其实是个极好的建议。感谢你提出这个建议。我们有一套——我的意思是，我们有一份点子清单，但那个点子立刻就非常有用，特别是它很及时，因为 Windows Terminal 刚在 5 月 2 日宣布。
So thank you for that. And thank you all for listening, supporting the show and all of that. If you're new, welcome. This was a good episode to join the to listen to for the first time and we'll catch you all next month the intro music is axo by binar pilot programming throwdown is distributed under a creative commons attribution share alike 2.0 license you You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work,
所以谢谢你。也谢谢大家收听、支持节目以及所有的一切。如果你是新听众，欢迎。这是一期很适合第一次收听的节目，我们下个月见。片头曲是 Binar Pilot 的《Axo》。Programming Throwdown 在知识共享 署名-相同方式共享 2.0 协议下发布。您可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输本作品，
to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide an attribution to Patrick and I and share alike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
可以混编、改编本作品，但您必须署名我和帕特里克，并采用相同的许可证进行分享。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可留下评论。